[Music]
[Music]
we will persevere we will push on
who is still suing me i just want people
to bear that in mind
i'm
[Applause]
a little loud but the enthusiasm i like
yeah they're suing me you know
and there's something interesting too
that a little wrinkle that i haven't
been able to talk about
of the lawsuit until now i'm not gonna
say much but i will say
this is a name that i've been wanting to
say
ryan kavanagh this is
the piece of human turd this is a human
turd
who's behind this lawsuit against me
he's a billion he's like matt
but a billionaire so he's like part
owner of triller
and this whole lawsuit his lawyers told
us
is being funded by ryan kavanagh uh
basically you know to stifle my first
amendment
right to say that their fight sucks
which it did it did suck
you know this isn't about they trying to
make it seem like it's about piracy
the video they're they're trying to say
that we pirated has 50 views on it
right it's like bro that's not piracy
your show your
uh your fight didn't get views because
uh
your fight wasn't successful because of
my 50 views it was from my team
preparing dumbass ryan kavanagh
a lot to say about him more coming up
later but
uh so that's something stressful that's
going on
yeah but anyway but let's talk about the
oh today's episode is sponsored by shady
rays
but you know the lawsuit's been on my
mind so much and i've been wanting to
talk about i've been waiting
i've been trying in good faith to
resolve this with them and it's just
it's come to the point where it's like
okay matt hoss with a billion dollars
oh gabe's gone it's friday you know what
it is
gabe where are you you're at a ball game
yeah
it's friday baby yeah chicago baby
[Applause]
it's friday it's friday
it's friday baby yeah what are we
are we eating some dogs drinking some
beer
cracker jacks baby cracker jacks let's
go
it's friday no school no work
yeah it's friday baby who's that guy
behind you drinking a beer
who's that guy behind you in the penn
state i have like
four or five baby yeah oh he's drunk
are you drunk gabe
thank you gabe thank you bro appreciate
that
yeah baby good luck to the cubs all
right have a fun time at the ball game
we love that for you
all right all right take care thanks for
checking in on us
sir white clock gabe everybody love you
buddy happy friday
i love that man he's a he's a pure soul
it's just gabriel he's that dude i gotta
say white club gabe has the best
life he's always doing something awesome
right like damn dude that a ball game
he's calling in
love that man white clock gabe you can
find him everywhere he's on cameo
support that man
anyway i've been wanting to talk about
the lawsuit so it's getting to the point
where it's like all right it's show time
you all they want me to pay them like
you know
a hundred thousand dollars plus it's a
total shakedown i'm like okay you know
what
you're just gonna have to you're just
gonna ha bro it's like bruh
i'm a i'm a i'm a i'm i'm basically a a
first amendment activist
i mean the last time matt hoss tried to
shake me down for four thousand dollars
and i said
[ __ ] you and we went to court instead of
legal precedence so now ryan kavanaugh
matt house 2.0 is trying to do the same
thing
and i'm and you think i'm if i'm not
going to pay matt haas four thousand
dollars i'm gonna pay brian kevin off a
hundred thousand dollars
[ __ ] no ryan cavanaugh such a douche
[ __ ] this guy bro i'm gonna tell you
guys about ryan kavanagh
here i'm just gonna read we're really
doing this now
i'm hey i'm not gonna sit here i'm just
gonna type ryan cavanaugh
by the way this is so this is the guy
i'm going to war with now
he's the ceo former ceo of relativity
media this is like a big thing
it's like a huge production company
and i'm not gonna but i'll say this he
does resemble harvey weinstein
physically and that's all i'll say about
that
you know what i mean i i'm just saying
he looks like harvey weinstein
i'm not saying anything other than that
like he looks like harvey weinstein oh
my god
don't you think he resembles him i mean
no no not really well he's got the beard
he's like the producer
i see it thank you amy come on guys work
with me here
he does resemble him in my humble
opinion of course imp
and um well here if you just go to like
ryan kavanagh
scandal and this is just what's on the
internet
here like for example if you go to
variety.com that's a rapid
ryan kevin accused by ex-partner of
running a ponzi scheme
nice that's written that was written by
variety which is like a pretty
that's like a reputable you know
yeah oh ryan kavanagh and this guy's got
the balls to come try to sue me
when his act when his you know variety
wrote this
this is just from 2019 accused by
ex-partner of running a ponzi scheme
this guy ryan kavanagh that looks like
harvey weinstein
he does here let me pull up a harvey
weinstein photo you can come on toss me
a bone here
harvey are we weinstein
let's get it side by side bro there's
total resemblance
how are you gonna say not sleazy
sleazy producer beard
you know a little chunky god bless i'm
chunky too no hate
come on you know
anyway apparently according to his
partner ex-partner he's runs a ponzi
scheme that sounds super illegal
shady that's not the kind of guy i would
want running
being involved in my business like
triller i wouldn't want that guy
involved in my business
no but also there's other scandals too
if you just google
ryan kavanagh scandal look at this one
about sexual harassment
oh deadline relativity
fabricated memo all right what's this
about
well he was the ceo of relativity um
you know here it says updated
relativity kavanaugh response but
it says claiming sexual harassment
against former
co-president oh it's about adam field
but it has here let me find a different
article
what i'm just reading what's on the
internet we are off the rail this isn't
off the rails
we are severely off just reading what's
on the internet this is the los angeles
times look
l.a times i'm not making these claims
this is the guy that's suing me trying
to
trying to infringe on my first amendment
right to say his fight sucks
and that in my opinion he greatly
exaggerated the pay-per-view numbers for
example
showtime very reputable
fight source i just got to get this off
my chest you got to go with me here
i have something good to say about this
showtime floyd mayweather
the ultimate prize fighter
first logan paul they said they sold a
million pay-per-view
and and trailers claiming that they sold
more than mayweather
first logan paul so in my humble opinion
you know they're lying about their
numbers that's just you know
my opinion but anyway here's another
headline
uh former relativity executive accuses
founder of fraud
and alleges porn activity in office
that's the los angeles times ryan
cavanaugh the founder and ceo relativity
media that's him
[Music]
come on you douche
don't you think he looks like harvey
weinstein
and don't really see it except that they
both have a beard
right zach in the discord said uh he
sees it
thank you zach's got your back because
zach i thought you weren't feeling well
he's not he's at home zach is not here
today i am actually sitting in his seat
uh running the audio today so shout out
to zach and his family
yo ryan kavanagh thank you shredder he
doesn't like ryan either
ryan cavanaugh the founder and chief
executive relativity media has been hit
with a lawsuit by a former executive at
the studio who accuses the once
high-flying media executive hiring him
on false pretenses and then improperly
firing him what a dish
what's that l.a times folks not a not a
joke paper
so there's plenty to say about this guy
ryan cavanaugh the failing la times
so this is the guy that's suing me so
i've got a billionaire now trying to
trying to take go to war with me so
yeah i got a lot of my mind
what else is on your mind yeah i guess
there's other stuff too
all right should we do the baby
update uh yeah all right baby update
oh did i thank our sponsor shady raise
yes
oh no no no no
do you got to double check his net worth
this one says he's worth 50 million
he's worth a billion look double check
that
everyone i talked to about him says he's
a billionaire
i'm seeing that he was at one point you
think he lost at all yeah they're saying
that he was uh a billionaire forbes
billionaire's rankings in 2015
and he lost his status how did he how
did he going from wait going from a
billion to 50 million is that that's
that's well he he filed bankruptcy and
he he supposedly
blew through a hundred million [ __ ]
loser hold on
i mean what a loser what a dude
and this guy's trying to spend his last
pennies fighting me no wonder he's so
scared because trailer is definitely
going to go bankrupt this is like a hail
mary for him so he's like i could assume
this guy
ryan you're gonna i'm gonna ryan this is
not good for you
that's what i try to be like ryan ryan
let's not do this
all right kavanagh
you know why all kavanaugh's are douche
brett kavanaugh
you like beer you like beer senator
okay anyway nobody cares about well i
care about ryan kavanagh
so the guy filed bankruptcy even after
his ex-partner said he was running apart
okay do you like your senator you'd like
me or senator do you like br senator
anyway we drank beer we drank beer
i've seen that he filed twice in two
years two bankruptcies
and triller was his big comeback
trailer's his big comeback no wonder
this guy's so desperate to save face
interesting oh triller's definitely
going bankrupt what do you got for me
thank you oh this is so nice oh my god
apparently you guys wrote us a card in
the discord
yeah wow this is really sweet oh my god
you guys
i feel like the teacher that everyone
likes you know at the end of the year
and they're writing nice messages
oh i'm gonna read through this anyway
enough about that everyone we got it
like i said i'm gonna make a video on
the topic next week so ryan cavanaugh if
you're listening
i don't blame jake for leaving the
titanic
it's not even the titanic you have to be
something to be titanic just like the
seeking ship that is trailer
jake paul left triller to go to showtime
and i can't even fault him for it
because when you're being run by a
dude like ryan kavanagh who's done
bankruptcy twice and according to his
ex-partner
was running a ponzi scheme like come on
bro
imagine being ryan cavanaugh according
to la magazine i don't want to be sued
too
oh yeah yeah yeah i'm not saying that
you're right yeah
according to l.a magazine all right
you're really killing the people here
sorry people all right baby tom all
right
so we went
a little bit ultrasound and it's a
it's a weird one this is the this is
it's not what you expect it shocked me
because it was the last thing i expected
to hear
and i was really like i wasn't sure how
to feel about it at first because i was
just so
shocked yeah
well and keep it going keep the drum
roll going
keep it going i was gonna say it dan we
could wait dan please
stand up dan
stand up stand up come on dan
stand up dan
by the way did you guys see the video we
just posted we posted a video it was
awesome
all right it's one baby oh
one baby i know it's crazy
all right you can stop the drum roll can
we get a cymbal crash or something
tan it's still a drum roll
zack is sick so dan's filling in for him
so um
[Laughter]
we don't know what happened there's one
baby
that baby was too powerful just kicked
out the other that's what the doctor
said it was just that baby was so
powerful so when we the last time we
went
the doctor was literally like you're
having
you're having two to three babies she
was like well there's definitely two
here and then i see a third one
that maybe not a third one but there's
definitely two
and then when we checked into the doctor
she's like checking in for four
to ela yeah they remembered
um and the whole week we were like
planning for like what is it gonna look
like if we have three babies it's like i
gotta get i gotta move i gotta get a new
car
i gotta i gotta hire like ten nannies
yeah um
so yeah i don't know i guess at first it
was kind of
weird reaction because it's like i was
ready
we were all yeah we were getting pretty
ready for three like
or two i mean you gotta make the best of
it so we were like well if it's three
let's prepare
but i mean i kind of feel like
relieved that it's one because i i
already have back pain
i was telling ethan like a few days this
week i was like
my back hurts so i'm really worried like
what is it gonna be later
um so i'm relieved
yeah i kind of am too at first i was a
little like
almost sad because
i was just expecting multiples and i was
like
i was ready to bring these much kids
into the world i was ready to do this
whole thing
but so like but you know i'm i'm happy
no matter what i was like not one kid
it's funny because we it's been such a
roller coaster we're like yeah 20
[ __ ]
so many kids and then now it's like oh
just like we wanted in our first place
okay
yeah so um
so i'm happy because it means that my
life is gonna be a lot less stressful
yeah and people are starting to tell me
like oh you're probably gonna be on bed
rest
and it's like c-section um
yeah like if it was three i think
towards the end i wouldn't even be able
to walk
i don't know um
so
it's all good news great news just
shocking it was
just it was like the last thing i
expected because the doctor put she got
you all ready to do the
is it an ultrasound yes and she's like
okay here i was like oh god i was like
oh just break it to me dog
just break it to me just tell me what is
damage
and she's like well no no no it's just
one baby
and we could see it there was a
heartbeat there's like one powerful baby
she did say there's a little something
that might be the second one but a very
small chance
it was like it's probably nothing yeah
apparently the other eggs just evaporate
or something i don't know what happens
in there in your body
there was a war oh god
this baby's a fighter been fighting for
survival since he won
well the good news is this could have
been you south
african woman gives birth to 10 babies
this was a world record right so also
this week everyone was telling me about
this
oh really yeah look how big she is
yeah that's exactly what what i was
feeling like i was gonna look like so
how do you have 10 babies like let's be
honest she released 10 eggs and they all
got fertilized like
that what
did do they show their babies or just
this picture seven boys and three girls
and so uh i read the article i think six
or seven of them were natural birth
and then the rest were c-section holy
god
yeah this is a world record in 2019
in 2009 eight babies held the previous
world record get
[ __ ] her she's off the books now
nobody's gonna remember her dumbass
but she's fine yeah she's fine
everyone's great that's crazy
how how do you how does your body
produce 10 eggs
and then the dudes so powerful not the
first one i just saw
someone said in the chat that's the
powerful that's one powerful load my
dudes
that is like that is just fertility
heaven i don't know
that's crazy
this woman could repopulate the whole
earth if she had to
god damn her name is
gaucian femara
[ __ ] look it says [ __ ]
what excuse me are you you're not set
no sith hole oh jeez but it's close
it says almost as [ __ ] all uh someone in
the
chat just donated uh 35 zar which i
believe is the currency of south africa
and they're saying uh i'm from south
africa and they cannot confirm the ten
babies oh really
yeah oh it's a myth why is this in bbc
news if they're
if this is like some unknown well in the
article it does it
it does say guinness world record is
currently investigating the claim
so it's it hasn't been officiated why
are these people lying about having 10
kids that's outrageous
well i don't know if it's uh that
they're lying it just
how do you ideas it just hasn't been
confirmed yet it just hasn't been
confirmed how do you get the number
wrong of babies born
they want that 10 baby clout exactly
they want that record but they didn't
earn a stolen valor
also um another donation unrelated
said i heard you mentioned sexual side
effects from lexapro
oh yeah i started taking mine at bedtime
instead of the morning and it helped a
bunch
thank you yeah i've tried everything my
dick is like uh
well you just changed it to nighttime my
dick has like permanent novocaine in it
but you just changed to night time yeah
i started taking it at night because i
was feeling tired during the day so i
was wondering i think it did help
so it's nice yeah i started taking it at
night i do notice though like i guess it
depends when you
uh do it because i found that it's
i have less sensitivity right after
taking the pill and then later in the
day or for you know
so it depends if you like to engage in
the evening or the morning you know what
i'm saying
it bro shout out so anyway we're gonna
have one
beautiful god willing beautiful healthy
baby right
but that means you have to give birth
again if we want more kids because we i
was kind of like
let's just let's just get right into it
in the words of phillyd
i know but it's like kind of easy to say
oh
you know
so
let's just get right in that's what i
see to ila before we try to conceive
i go eli you ready right into it
that's philip defranco we haven't played
that one in a while but
we put together or somebody did maybe
not us philip defranco the top of all
the shows goes sup
sup people it wasn't us some some
hero did that for us so we have the sub
bomb
anyway we have a great show planned
today a lot of fun stuff uh
a lot of really fun stuff oh you know
what
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna say anything
about trisha the only thing i do want to
say is because
a lot of people have been asking
there was this issue a lot of people
were upset about of trisha getting
50 of the membership money
and i just want to say because a lot of
people were asking that now that
obviously frenemies is over there
wouldn't be
any there wouldn't be any need to pay
her
membership money right so that money is
no longer going to be going to trish as
a lot of people were asking
so thank you thank you and one more
comment
um you can add wellbutrin
wellbutrin to lexapro to help with
sexual side effects
tiredness what's wellbutrin isn't that
another antidepressant apparently it's
something that works let's double up
bro in addition to it he was really
looking for a solution for this
i said i love it um no i know why you
said
look he's really i just find it
interesting i mean
eli you gotta you got something you want
to say
i just find it interesting uh-huh
why so interesting you you just like to
be the victim don't you
you just wanna be like stop it oh i have
no feeling
so okay i won't try to help i'll just
watch
happily find this just joking because i
think people are going to infer that
you're like
unhappy with my penis no i don't like
desperately hearing
i'm just making jokes by the way when
you say feelings you mean
feelings not in my heart but my job yes
i
know my heart is full of god what the
[ __ ]
my heart is full of love for you i don't
like it all right
can we wait with the dad jokes for like
i thought you were doing a tricia
impression for a minute
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] when you
were like oh you're just the victim
i was not she's infiltrated [ __ ]
i find it interesting all right and i
like the other people in the chat
finding it interesting
half of the world like the
i'm just kidding all right i'm sorry
tell me about what will buchan does with
lexapro
um are you having a [ __ ] about what are
you happy with my penis
i'm not talking i'm silent
you are right it's all good there yes
thank you
just for the people
everyone in the chat is saying they're
taking it by the way
well butchering plus lucky yes well
where's my dumbass doctor with the webb
exactly double me up doc
i didn't know that was a thing me
neither that's why i thought i was
interested it was interesting thank you
yeah there was another 100 donation um
that uh said i also got some wellbutrin
and now my ovaries feel
a little less dried and shriveled well
that that's
kind of a good review i jesus guess
let's get some wellbutrin in the house
um so anyway that's that yadda yadda
god i don't know if you i've just been
so stressed i've honestly okay i'm going
to be level with you guys
depending on stress will go of
everything
my tourette's has been really bad have
you noticed that i've been like
twitching a lot am i
i'm really starting to damage my wrist i
started doing this wrist thing and like
i can't even like barely hold on to [ __ ]
anymore oh wow
not because it's just my muscles are
sore like when i pick up a cup
because sometimes you guys may not even
see this but i do like this and the
muscle gets so strained that
it's really annoying that sucks you know
that this other tic i do that really
messes me up
is i squeeze my butthole you do it's a
thick
yeah huh i squeezed it but the thing is
about squeezing the butthole
is that it increases your blood pressure
oh no i guess i shouldn't have seen a
dog i shouldn't laugh
yeah that is serious it's funny i'm
doing it it is funny not if it has like
a serious side of it listen you can
laugh
but sometimes when i squeeze my butthole
a lot i can feel like my heart pumping
and i just it really [ __ ] up my body
yeah they tell you when you're doing a
um
a lie detector test that if you want to
mess with the results you squeeze your
butthole
because it really messes up your blood
pressure and you can't they can't tell
if you're giving a positive or negative
answer okay
try it feel it i mean just yeah it's
it's you
you know what everybody's doing it's 80
000 people right now
are squeezing their buttholes no it's
intense it really can get to you when
you squeeze and squeeze
all the time squeezing squeezing
squeezing
it's like a kegel though so so strong in
that regard
do you think you should see a doctor
though about this stuff what can you do
i mean i don't think
it's not a treatable it's not really
treatable tourette's
it's just like good luck idiot
that's what god says when you're born
with duress good luck idiot
best of luck [ __ ] face
that's probably the worst tick i've had
is when i squeeze my butthole because i
feel like
sometimes it's just like oh my whole
body goes haywire
i never knew about that one yeah well
you know
and another one well there's one i used
to have when i was kid was probably even
worse than the butthole squeezing
which was i would shake my head like
this and i used to get these
unbelievable headaches from like jarring
my
head the worst
but listen why am i just complaining all
i'm just like you're sitting here
complaining
sad um i guess
you know it's been a tough week sad
ethan this is the worst podcast episode
sad ethan we have a really good episode
i promise
um ethan's feet love you want to talk
about this because you said this was
this is basically since i got banned on
wikifee
um right it's not
perfected yet but i have been working on
a alternate alternative
and last time i showed you i hadn't
pinned you at the top
so i did uh go ahead and up your score
a bit there thank you how many times is
that ten
beautiful yeah why you say my shoe size
seven that's not true
why you would do me like that yeah well
we um
that's just like uh template
data we gotta fine-tune the website a
little bit it's definitely a bit
uh are these fake comments or real
comments no it's real comments
so if you see write the review yo these
are real
the love yeah they built this whole
website i never believed in love at
first
sight until i witnessed ethan's feet on
wikifee sadly as with any true love we
were torn apart by the great band of
2021.
i spent months pondering the point of
trying to love if it always disappears
and why live if you can't love
it wasn't until recently these feet
walked back into my life
i give you my honor as the king of
wikifeed and the stomper of my heart
forever your night
demoni di damoni cade
bro who wrote that
so poet
love at first sight on love's sight
shout out to his family
yeah this is awesome also another
audition that i did
check under your name oh yeah is this a
sound bite
yeah is it working oh
working in progress well i think that's
an orange i think the website i think
oh we crashed it
well we're working on that we're gonna
have to you know what we're gonna have
to fund the hosting on that yeah
yeah the funding right now costs five
dollars yeah so that might not be enough
we got to step that up
ethan's feet there you go thank you love
i appreciate that it really means a lot
to me
of course um
you guys want to get an update from
wally sure
now this i gotta be honest this is like
a dance thing
don't don't do no it's not just me it's
me too yeah
it's really all of us we kind of felt
that well it's he's not good i mean i
like him he's okay but like i don't i
don't know if i love him as much as you
guys do
just in the same way that like
let's be honest there's people that we
all love more than others
but this is your guy i'm doing this for
you guys so here's wali thank you thank
you here's wally guys an update from
wally
everyday
[Applause]
[Applause]
dude this is way too long this is tick
tock you don't have to watch the whole
thing
i'm out that's the first pick that was
too long for me
to be honest with you
[Music]
okay so let me try by then wally
soon you go to hell well the gravelly
one i can understand i can do that one
it's the crazy
okay that's pretty close
really tears my throat up that's pretty
good though i tell you i can do it
i'm not impressed by wally
um
yo okay you
so sorry to interrupt we we got to go to
break oh we actually do have to go to
break
we have too much fun out here you know
before we go to break i just want to
tell you guys
we got um so much i promise we have such
a dude we're talking about jail talk
today
this is something that has endlessly
fascinated me there's a whole genre of
content on tick tock of people in jail
they've like i don't know they snuck in
smartphones i don't know how
hello good [ __ ] dude we're
we've got a pickup so we know if people
in jail get to have a phone or like
no way yeah yeah so
how does that work and they make videos
they mostly sneak them in by bribing the
guards
you got to see these they're amazing all
right let's do we only have one ad today
so let's blast through this shady rays
we love you shady ray
i'm gonna run and by the way it's not
that he's shady
he just wears glasses yeah that's cool
nothing shady here except the sun not
being in your eyes
listen listen why are sunglasses so
expensive
shady rays went out to change that baby
it's an independent sunglass company
that do things their own way
that's a very loud notification sound
also can i get some music to get me in
the
zone zone me out
let's see something that is very rare in
the industry uh
what kind of music here i i'm not i'm
i'm sitting at
zach station here so i'll play something
damn about the magical forest
yeah how's that sound
let's hear it sounds shady to me
oh that's the harry potter music okay
let's not get copyrighted
well no i mean like we were using it the
other day for the harry potter rays
you have some like sprinkle magical
sprinkle sounds yeah let me see what's
that one instrument where you like
run your finger over the tubes uh just
i want that a vibraphone
shady rays are premium polarized shades
at a fraction of the price of the big
name brands
stop overpaying for sunglasses that
you're too afraid to get dirty
like that these you can toss around put
in your pocket it don't matter because
they're not a thousand billion dollars
save your dollars and gain peace of mind
with the best
most affordable shades for the outdoors
what's the best part about shady rays
they have the craziest warranty or
warranty come on ethan craziest warranty
in all of eyewear lost broken whatever
it's getting replaced if you lose or
break your shades one day
they told us that they will send you a
brand new pair no questions asked
damn bruh dropped in the lake ocean
anything they'll replace them god
damn every pair of shady rays is
guaranteed for life so take it on your
next adventure
with the team that has your back shady
razilla
nice even with this even with that
strong warranty
they still manage to make the quality
that holding
you holding uh
you can hold in your hand and it feels
expensive high quality it's just like
the big brands boys
they got those the polarized lenses that
look perfectly clear
and they started just 48 dollars say
what
[Music]
hold pairs try them do whatever be
genuine oh that's a no for me
ignore that cut that out then
shady rays also provides 10 meals to
fight hunger in america with every order
placed and have donated over 15 million
meals to date
oh and they're also saints did we
mention
they stand behind their product and they
stand behind the product and told our
team that if anyone has a problem they
throw profit out the window and do
whatever it takes to make them
right free returns and exchanges you
either love the shades
or shady rays will ship pay them back
bruh i can't read today
you either love the shades or shady rays
will pay to ship them back that's it
change the way you wear sunglasses and
give shady rays a risk-free shot
we think you're gonna love them so uh
and if you're not you
what i'm sorry ela can you read this
read this where just the yellow part
change the way you wear sunglasses and
give shetty rays
a risk-free shot we think you're going
to love them
and if they're not for you you can
return them for free
anyways exclusively for our listeners
chatty race is running
their deepest deal of the season use
code h3 for 50
off two or more pairs of shadyrays.com
or at shettyrays.com i'm already messing
up
buy one get one free you can get two
pairs for 48
redeem only at shadyrace.com
where you can find all their newest and
best shades wow that's two pre
use code h3 for fifty percent off two or
more pairs at shadyrace.com thank you
buy one get one free christ that was
like a ten minute like
it was like the anyway you were yawning
oh i don't know what's wrong you know
what the theodore is like oh
right dude he's been coming into our
room like three times in the night
he came in at like 3 a.m this tonight
and then
arguing about whose turn it is to take
them
he was on your side going mommy he
always comes to my side that doesn't
mean anything
he goes mommy and then ila wakes me up
and goes dad
i'm like man teddy got crane
teddy got the crane teddy got the crane
it all changed since he got that crank
it's all changed
so it's hard i don't know what to do i
don't know if like i don't know if
they're
life is not the same yeah i don't know
if we're
if there's something we need to do
because like i take him back to his
bedroom
and put him down and then he goes daddy
sit daddy sit
because if you don't sit with him he'll
freak out i wonder if we have to like
train him that we don't sit there right
maybe that's gotta be that's the other
night i was like listen buddy daddy's
sleepy he has to sleep too
and he goes as soon as he heard that he
goes
mommy and i was
yeah maybe you're right it's so hard i
don't know what to do with this
yeah it's been it's every night i mean
i'm sure someday he'll get over it i
just don't know if it's like you know
in two weeks or in like five years yeah
could just lock our door be like sorry
oh my god
um look at this i like making fun of all
these old idiots
these people are elected officials bro
you you know like you wonder why the
country is such a [ __ ]
i mean i look bro
okay stop this guy literally he's he's a
representative mo
brooks he's just tweeting some [ __ ]
who cares
he literally
okay there's a he posted a picture of
his [ __ ]
monitor which is already like old people
as [ __ ]
and on the bottom is a sticky pad with
his password and pin code
[Laughter]
you can literally see his password and
pin code
he masking taped it to his monitor this
is a
this is a representative
these people could not be trusted he is
a representative from
alabama's fifth uh congressional
district
let me guess is he a republican of
course he is
sorry i mean he just is you know he is
like you just know he is
i didn't even read what he wrote well
swahwell finally did his job
horrible swat welsh team committed a
crime by unloving what dude
all of these dudes try and do the trump
thing of giving people nicknames and
none of them are good at it like he is
poor people swallow
that's the worst [ __ ] nickname trump
was like he was so
good at that and giving somebody a
really [ __ ] aren't funny or
interesting
most of them are honestly just dumb as
hell like they just look more stupid
when they try to do the trump
horrible swalwell here i'll give i don't
know anything who's eric schwab i'll
give him a name right now
who's eric swallow he's a representative
from here in southern california i
believe
let me see a photo of him i think i know
who he is yeah i don't even know
i'm gonna give him that i'm gonna give
him a nickname oh yeah this guy yeah i
know who he is
yeah slow well eric slow
not that good better than his horrible
swalwell
how about this one
yeah where is it is that me well it
shouldn't be right
my whole laptop is muted so it can't be
me
i like i like slow well what's wrong
with that
it's all right because it's gotta be
like
slow eric slow slowwell slow eric
slow eric that's a trump name goofy slow
eric
oh it could be mine i'm [ __ ] it up
it's definitely mine okay
of course because i open wait no it's
not open it's not me it's not
force quit first quit okay
anyway you know it's like it happens
ethan no problem
uh we haven't proven that it was me it's
not over
um some people are asking about the
teddy fresh that we're wearing so it's
from the next release
which is gonna be on june 24.
so stay tuned thank you thank you peace
and love dan you did you guys have a
hate email that you wanted to read
oh right okay i got this email the other
day
and you know i get a lot of goofy emails
and usually i just
but for some reason this one really got
me
okay so the subject line i won't say who
it's from but the subject line is please
fix your eyebrow situation
have a eyebrow situation well let me let
me read the email okay
hi dan your girlfriend must love you i
say this because only a woman
afraid of losing her man would allow him
to groom his eyebrows with a razor the
way that you have
the gap is too large and the lines are
too straight and harsh
bless her heart she just doesn't want to
lose you who could blame her
i used to find you attractive
[Laughter]
it made me happy to watch you on h3h3
because you there is a dearth of smart
conscientious cute men in general
now you are less cute this is not good
for either of us
those puppies should go grow back quick
please let them may i suggest a subtle
plucking strategy
you clear the center and then angle the
edges the straight lines you created
with the razor are too abrupt and look
unnatural
google young harrison ford or recent tom
cruise photos
or decent plucking examples i look
forward to your hotness returning
i don't know that one it just did you
[ __ ] crack wait did you groom your
eyebrows well i
i have a unibrow and like it naturally
grows in the middle and
since i was like 13 years old or
something and since i was 13 years old
or something i've
taken a little razor and just gone so
they're right you were
so this is yeah i mean but this is not
new i i agree that's good advice
and and i guess i appreciate it it's
just
i've never gotten such a good like
backhanded compliment i guess i thought
about your eyebrows wait this person
really cares about your eyebrows i know
and i well so i'm going to let them grow
out i'm going to try you're going to do
a pluck now
i guess i guess it's a good strategy
i mean what do i know about [ __ ]
grooming might groom your eyebrows maybe
yeah tell me about your middle part tell
me about your grooming
i just lean on plucking where i'll pluck
them that's only the middle only in the
middle yeah my
i mean like rarely i'll get a couple on
like top like high up for some reason
but that's it
really got middle eastern brows
i'm half russian half scottish both of
which are fairly hairy
uh i think that's pretty cool to groom
the eyebrows
i'd i guess i i i don't have much
somehow i didn't get the double eyebrow
which it doesn't make much sense because
i
have hair everywhere else that i
shouldn't you're just not that like
middle eastern i guess but although
dan is not either i don't know but dan's
a pretty hairy dude
i'm a very hairy dude all right
don't shave your eyebrows i agree oh you
know what i have a
i have an embarrassing story for you
guys you guys want to do this
embarrassing story thing
because i have like three and one just
came to me okay
so we're gonna do a story time right now
where we're all going to share our
cringe moments okay now i'm going to go
first because something just occurred to
me about
when i was uh in high school and i was
super self-conscious about my look like
utterly just
uh i would look in the mirror and i
would like
ruin my day i would look at a photo of
myself and it would just ruin my day
like it was so bad
and i just stopped looking at photos of
myself and looking in the mirror
which was great you know but anyway i
was so upset
i would start plucking my eyebrows and
you know
for there's like tiny bit in the in the
middle that i don't pluck anymore but
i start there you get do you ever you
take it too far right you know what i
mean
you pluck in the middle and then the top
you know and then the side
and then all the sudden you're looking
you're obviously going for a natural
look but all of a sudden you got these
little pencil thin
eyebrows and it just looks mangled and
like just
horrible yeah
so every day i'm going deeper and deeper
and not realizing how like uh
like horrible i'm looking and it
happened one time
i was at dinner with my whole family
and it was my brother-in-law who said
this of all people i don't know why he
was the one but i'm i'm grateful
and he goes yo ethan and i i didn't even
think anybody knew that i was plucking
my eyebrows because i found it
embarrassing i was like humiliated by it
for some reason
and um he's like ethan
you're going too crazy with the eyebrows
dude you got to stop
he just said that to me in front of the
whole family and i was
i didn't i don't know why my dom proof
essence
people best in brain it was like oh my
god
they know everybody knows not them not
them
everybody knows i've been going to
school like this for like a month
everybody knows that i'm
massacring my eyebrows sheesh
it was a moment of pure terror and i
never plucked another
eyebrow hair again as long as i lived
yeah so you were doing it out of stress
no i was trying to look good oh i was
trying to shape my eyebrows
because i would look at the cute boys
that all the girls like and i was like
you know what's the difference between
me and them
their eyebrows swear you're to god
back then in middle school oh god i'm
like that's why she likes him and not me
because his eyebrows look perfect
and so i was trying to make me have
these cute boy you know
eyebrows
i would look at doing but he has such
striking eyebrows
swear to god i do my own eyebrows too by
the way yeah you have crazy eyebrows and
i people say that about you
i do hate sometimes if i'll go too much
and then it
becomes too thin or something i don't
know yeah it's a tough one
i just and as a young man i i found it
very humiliating
to even think that i was doing it
because i was like oh this isn't
masculine
to be plucking my eyebrows and i felt
very demasculated
i did i think that was a thing in our
age yeah
say what would you say dad it's
emasculated
thank you just say masculinity i feel
like today it's more normal
for guys yeah yeah i think jersey shore
kind of made it more mainstream with the
gtl
because before that no no guys would
ever admit and then they're all like oh
it's
you know it's part of the part of the
look now i hate to even admit it that i
still find it embarrassing for some
reason
to even like i don't know it's just such
a deep drama to me
it's such a jeep trauma to me of course
there's nothing wrong with it
you know there you have it i've got two
more stories you guys want to hear them
or you want to go
do yours i want to hear them
uh either way we can go around why don't
why don't
we do ours and then we'll come back
around to you yeah
zach's not here but he already told us
how he [ __ ] on the lawn
well we we mentioned that he was like
that's not my story i'm not embarrassed
by that yeah
i was like you should be like that
wasn't crazy what is the embarrassed by
eli do you have one you want to go
i actually don't because you guys only
told me about this yesterday
i thought you were last night and you
said oh you have one come on
i have a joke for you a joke so ask me
what is my story
my cringe story what's your cringe story
my whole life
oh my god oh boy
that's not funny oh you're alive you are
amazing you're not cringe
i don't know do you have one that you
can remember for me
because i feel like you know everything
about me
um you told me a story about when you
and your friends were like getting drunk
for the first time you drank and it was
like a total [ __ ] show
but i don't know if that's i don't know
if it's embarrassing i mean
what about the restaurant that made you
wear lipstick and a dress
i mean is it a crazy story i don't know
it's interesting though it's a powerful
woman's story
uh sure but it's embarra you felt
embarrassed to have to go wait tables
like
with lipstick and a dress right yeah
yeah
so i was i was going to
school and i had to work at the same
time so i was doing a lot of like
waitressing
jobs so one of them
they um yeah in one of them they were
like
here's the uniform and it's like a
little black dress
and they're like you'll have to wear
that and
a red lipstick and i was like
i don't even remember the details
anymore but i was just not comfortable
with that
so i quit oh well
that i mean very good
i don't know if there was more details i
think it does actually i think we're
mixing up two stories
one was the black dress and i was not
cool with that
another one was um first of all they
made
they made us like bring our own clothes
but they were very specific like you
need to wear this
white button-up shirt black pants black
shoes
and i didn't have that stuff i had to go
buy it especially for this job
and then on um it was like new year's
eve or something and they're like today
we want you all to wear red lipstick so
i was like
i'm not doing that they fired you i left
okay not that embarrassing because they
weren't it was like non-negotiable
i remember it being more traumatic i
don't want to wear
[Applause]
wow incredible what a star yeah
all right who's next ian go ahead stand
up ian
ian please stand up stand up ian
thank you ian why are you looking like
jumanji looking ass by the way show ian
like we've why
are we not even gonna acknowledge that
ian looks like jumanji
oh judge ian please stand up i don't
know please stand up
please stand up ian please stand up yeah
why do you have like a realistic jumanji
you stand up i just grab some other
closet
on the way is this the new uzi
can i i i keep pressing the wrong button
and it makes you freak out
but i get let me just do it
i should i just like when that happens
oh my god
what kind of setting could possibly
that's my fault
it's the zoom it's the zoom call it's
your feed on the zoom call
and then he takes it and then oh that's
creates an endless look
like this go ahead and do a face i'll
wait websites is on down
hold on try it
here we [ __ ] go wait can you do it so
it zooms on my face
it kind of goes along with whatever
motion so ethan like had to move yeah
thrust forward right as he does it okay
ready
yeah yeah wait do it again
that's terrifying first person reminds
me of han solo being frozen
carbonite thank you anyway ian tell me
your embarrassing cringe moment
in ian
uh the first one that ian
go ahead the first the first one that
pops into my head uh was the first day
of high school
where obviously as you can tell i'm a
super fashionable guy very you know hand
on the pulse
well show them what you're wearing don't
joke you're in the gym oh you can see it
i mean
no show them your feet oh you're wearing
you're in the jumanji outfit but you're
still you're not really committed
because you're wearing yeezys bro
you should be wearing some like leaves
or some [ __ ] that's rebark
i think robin williams and jumanji is
the target
for this type of fashion what year is it
are you she's out yet uh
so it's the first day and i i got to
school
big hallway ever was packed everyone at
the lockers and everything
and my backpack
i didn't realize that this wasn't cool
at the time because i thought it was
really cool in middle school but i
walked in
and and it was a roller back there
so you know i said it and i went
and then you roll it you know what i'm
talking about yeah and the moment i
started doing
that every single person in the hallway
just
looked right at me like what the [ __ ]
are you doing like
i was the only person in the entire high
school
that i saw that entire day with a roller
backpack
and i i carried it like in my hands for
the rest of the day because i was so
ashamed
i had a lot of you know fashion faux pas
in high school
you know i remember that about middle
school in high school is like you got
people made fun of you if you had one of
those
rolly backpacks well hold on a second uh
hold on a second
what what possessed you to get the
rolling backpack ian was that
on fashion or how did you make this
fashion
i mean convenience you made a risk you
made a risk and it didn't pay off
yeah yeah i also i i had healies on too
oh no no no no you did not
you were making that part
did you use them at the same time were
you rolling
rolling wall rolling while rolling you
know a little uh
a little oh my god i keep pers let me
press
there we go yeah that was the one i was
looking for
uh a little later on i
embraced the meme with the rollies and
people were like
where can i get some but that's good
the first day it was it was rough it was
a rough day
yeah that's not a good feeling you are
trend center he was ready to roll into a
whole pile of
[ __ ] was ready to be like i'm about
to get
laid hell yeah bro you know what i just
remembered one that maybe could work
here
okay please stand up ela okay
ian please stand up strainer
um it was when i was at the army and um
i all of a sudden had this awful
um stomach pain it was a poop story yeah
oh
[ __ ] he was about to share a poop story
oh oh
no not that embarrassing oh no like just
a little like
good luck so it was
i never had such a bad pain i thought it
was like something is wrong and i
i called my superiors and i was like my
stomach something is not right
and they're like let's get the paramedic
no this is amazing
this is amazing so they check me and
everything seems fine and they're like
maybe it's period and i'm like no i
didn't get my period
and they're like look nothing i'm like i
can't even stand it was like really
worrying everyone was worrying for me
and then i don't know like a few minutes
later i had to go to the bathroom
and it was just like i had to poop and
then after i pooped it was fine
you did you have to tell everyone that
you pooped are you just like i'm feeling
better now i told a couple of people
but did you tell the pet like yeah
because they're like a whole commotion
about it's just like
it's fine i'm fine now they probably got
it
they're probably like she just took a
massive dumb
was it gassy poop i honestly don't
remember i just remember like
how that's embarrassing the pain was
really i've had poops like that before
honestly
where you get so much abdominal pain
like what's going on
i know what you mean well when you lift
the doc you should see the diet she's on
in the army
mix no it doesn't surprise me you have
like killer death inducing poop
um candies coffee cigarettes
cigarettes shitty army food with a lot
of oil
did it sound like that um
maybe maybe i think i erased it from my
memory
that's great we all have embarrassing
group stories that's the best thing
about pooping
yeah i mean one of my embarrassing
stories was when i was in vegas and [ __ ]
myself
i was with my family wait like a week
ago no no no
i think i was in college at the time
i was with my family and i got like a i
got like really sick from
either food poisoning or i got a fever
or something
a flu and i was playing poker i was
having so much fun i was doing good just
enjoying myself
and then all of a sudden it was like one
of these moments where i'm playing cards
and it was like and i oop
and i was like oh buddy so i cashed out
i'm wearing basketball shorts you know
like elastic
kind of athletic um
and i am walking to
the back the hotel room that i'm sharing
with my brother
and i farted and it wasn't just like
it was a shark but it was running down
my leg
and because i was wearing short like
athletic shorts
and boxer pants briefs not briefs but
like boxer shorts
yeah very open it was literally able to
to drip down my leg past my pant line oh
god
so i had actually visible diarrhea
running down my leg as i was walking
through the casino
to the hotel room i had guys
i had diarrhea dripping down my leg i
was one of those people we made fun of
i didn't stop the wiping and throw it on
the floor or anything though
jesus i was trying to keep it yeah the
funniest part is i get into my room
and my brother's in the shower and he's
got the door locked to the bathroom
and i was like sean you better get out
right now dude i got it
something happened i need to get in
there
but people walked by me too and i was
just like please
i was like hey i was just like you know
i was walking like this
like hey how you doing nice to see you
got in the elevator i think there was
someone in the elevator with me
why like this to make your length your
legs like i was clenching my ass
so it was more like this because i was
trying to keep
i didn't want more trying to keep the
damn block
so i was walking around like this hey
nice to see you
how's the guy you win any money tonight
for you huh
yeah that was crazy i was so sick man
very embarrassing too
[Laughter]
well i think the only time i've [ __ ] my
pants as an adult
sometimes i think about it's pretty
remarkable that we all
aren't [ __ ] our pants more
like if you do the math
i i don't know if that's weird no it
makes sense i mean i i
totally get your point like if you [ __ ]
what two times a day
yeah seven days a week chances are so
that's 14 shits a week times 52 weeks
a year it's a lot of [ __ ] going on
times like what 20 years
how many shits is that yeah and there's
always been a toilet
that's correct the good news about
society today at least here in america
is that
the toilet per square footage is pretty
good
good ratio strong chance that you're
going to be caught like
in a position to shape i mean we've
we've engineered society so that people
don't [ __ ] their pants
a lot yeah and that i think is part of
what society really is
yeah that is you did civilization
there's a toilet
we do not have any [ __ ] on the street or
in our pants even
all right um does the guard give you
irritable bowel syndrome question from
the family i don't think so
all right i don't i've never heard of
that association
but everything's irritated irritated in
my body so who knows i mean my throat's
irritated my bowels are irritated my
brain is irritated
i'm irritated everything about me is
irritated
abe did you tell yours what's yours
uh yeah mine are kind of repressed it's
kind of bad
i i'm by the way let me stop abs is
always like
way worse than it should be so i'm
excited
i have yeah i tell it i make it sound
worse than what it is
is it going to wind up with somebody
yeah i accidentally ran
just dan dan check me if i come out
wrong all right
okay i'm sure you will i got my finger i
got the finger on your microphone
hit the kill switch so let me i guess
the audience
i may have confused them but my whole
life like i never smoked drink anything
or anything like that until i started
college there was a few years where i
did
and then i went back to the hello life i
went back to the to the late
but um like the first summer where i
started partnering partying you know i
thought i was a [ __ ] whatever but i
couldn't handle anything like i couldn't
smoke it was
it was a nightmare so i had a party one
night and some girl
messaged me and said oh thanks for the
invite like towards the end and i was
like uh
oh sorry you could still uh come through
because i was at a point in my life
where i
could talk like that come through but uh
she's like all right yeah for sure
let me know when everyone leaves so i
was trying to [ __ ] you that's what i
assumed i
so i texted her and she's like do you
want to smoke and i was like yeah okay
cool she's when she's outside she goes
oh i'm here and she goes just so you
know we're just hanging out
don't try anything and i'm never the one
to make the first move and i'm like oh
okay
cool let's that's fine okay i'm sorry
i'm misread so she came in
we smoked this was like weed from the
devil itself this was
i was tripping okay and so we go inside
and uh like i had no cable nothing
because
only thing i had were we watched movies
on the xbox and it was locked to my
roommate's room so
and he wasn't home so there's nothing
for us to do the only thing i had at the
house was this
donkey kong game called uh donkey kong i
believe was called you guys were playing
donkey kong
donkey kong it's the one with like the
little bongos i tried talking to her
nothing she didn't want to do anything
she didn't want to conversate or uh
why'd she come over what is this i was
just i don't know so the only game i
came over after the party only when
everyone was gone to play donkey kong
with you
i sent in the discord if you guys aren't
familiar you you play this game with
drums yeah let me pull up a photo yeah
it's like uh
oh i totally miss the that looks fun
it's like they it does you you move like
this okay it's like a ddr kind of thing
yeah you move like that and you clap to
jump
love that for it and so i'm stoned out
of my mind and she's not talking to me
and i'm just playing donkey kong
we're all drunk and like my heart's
going with the drums and every time like
i would like clap
i'd give her a little look because she's
staring at she's why wait why
she's staring at me wait why were you
looking at her when you clap i
i don't know i was like i knew how
ridiculous it was
but at the same time yeah like what was
her reaction and i think i was so high
that i actually
like was paying to attention to the game
as well so every time
i look and she give me that look and i
get nervous and i start going
faster on the drums and
uh it was a [ __ ] nightmare i it felt
like
[ __ ] years i was in that room playing
donkey kong and she's like all right i
gotta go i was like
all right and then she left and she goes
man you're a little [ __ ] yeah she texts
me
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
what she said that's you said you're
being a little [ __ ]
she thought that i wasn't making a move
because
she's she was cool with my ex at the
time so she thought
i wasn't making a move because of that
i'm like you said we're just hanging out
and i was
expecting that she goes are you serious
she's like i came over at like 2 a.m
to smoke with you i'm like but you you
[ __ ] said we're just hanging out
playing donkey kong so thank you for
this dude
well first of all obviously you did the
right thing you can't make a move on a
girl right yeah that's right
yeah she said it's like i didn't know
what else to do i didn't know we didn't
have any other activities
ladies if you want something you just
this this is our job men if you tell us
something you want we just believe you
mm-hmm in today's world we're not taking
there's no risk there's no great lines
you say with this we do that
you say this we do that so a b you did
you say no sex we play donkey yes
and i like repressed it it wasn't until
i was at thanksgiving at lena's
uh cousin's house and her little nephew
brought out the little
bongo roms and i was like oh my god
keep that away from me so when she
called you a little [ __ ] on the way out
did you guys talk anymore did she just
leave you with that
uh we hooked up another time but uh
okay i didn't ask that jesus
i mean yeah i mean uh
no but did she would you want to know on
that conversation
oh if she said anything did she say
anything else did you just leave you
with your little [ __ ] oh no yeah no i
she's she said that oh you're acting
this way because your ex
oh so you guys had overcomers yeah
because i was wondering if it [ __ ]
with your head where she's like your
little [ __ ] and then bounced and didn't
explain what happened
okay that was a nightmare it reminds me
of the time that we were at
uh i think it was that post malone's and
there was a chocolate on the counter
yeah and then i assumed that it was
normal chocolate
oh i'm glad you said that you're like
i'm sorry to cut you off but yeah
that's kind of what i was trying to
apply with the story of me and lena that
i told on a previous episode with oj but
i guess it came out wrong and people
thought i
dosed my wife and then admitted it on an
episode that wasn't live and then we
posted it
i don't know but i'm sorry proceed
so yeah i i was just like this looks
like a regular chocolate
and it took like a whole cube and then
they told us that it was not
and i think we went right back home and
i think
that like you fell asleep and i put on
um it was around the time that the bill
nye on netflix show came out and it was
like
horrible everyone was goofing on bill so
bad and i put that on and i watched the
whole season and i was like
did you learn were you able to pay
attention it was all a blur
right boy that bill and i
as a fan of bill nyes as a kid boy that
netflix show was
more so bad i never watched it because i
just
i didn't want to but it was like ruined
my image of him from my childhood it was
really weird
yeah just wasn't in it because the bill
nye kid show was like super well
produced with segments and stuff
this was all alive it was odd man it was
awesome i think that's the thing is like
because i love the bill nye show too
budget but yeah i think
i think what made that show was was all
the production like it was just
yeah yeah it was i don't want to get to
know bill and i on a personal level
right yeah it was the quick cuts and the
energy yeah unlike anything you'd see in
the school room
right if you guys are looking for
something really bad to watch i
recommend
kind of it's a fun like bad thing to
watch yeah
it's a good bad one bill nye the science
guy
bill bill that was yo when people put on
bill nye
that was when you had a substitute
teacher and you knew you were just hype
as [ __ ]
yeah bill not yeah exactly friday
afternoon
you got the substitute teacher bill nye
this science card
bill no bill hey it's friday baby
i missed i gotta be honest i miss those
like fridays bro
fry didn't really mean [ __ ] to me
anymore
it's sort i mean we get pretty excited
when we're done with this show and we're
we're out of here for the weekend baby
fridays are tough
the weekends are tough bro in our house
it's so tough
i feel like i'll be honest with you guys
i feel like i'm burning on both ends
these days i know you feel the same way
too either
yeah i think we're deciding that we
might need help on the weekend too
because
it's like you need some time to relax
i have no time the weekend oh the
opposite it's like
the week is almost chiller than the
weekend so we
in a way there's like no break
um like yesterday we worked we had the
we had a really long day yesterday we
went to the doctor we worked all day
got home took care of the theater the
dogs put her to bed and then immediately
i came worked on the show for today and
also went to bed
when we got home there was still a lot
of things going on and we had a lot of
calls
yeah so it was literally non-stop no it
was non-stop and then
right after i finished preparing for
today i went straight to bed
fall asleep and then theodore at 3 a.m
and then and then he came again at six
yeah right away he's been doing two
stops in the middle of the night bro
it's brutal
you know so funny though like it's so
cute when it comes into our bedroom
he came in once at 11 00 p.m we were
preparing for dinner yeah he came in
like a little ninja
for dinner we were preparing for him for
bed sorry i love him
yeah and so when he for some reason when
he wakes up he
gets everything all of his possessions
so he's got this thing called lovers
which are like
these little blankets with animals
stuffed animal heads on the top yeah
like a little elephant head and then a
blankie it's a cute little thing that he
loves
and he's got a bunch of them so he'll
grab like literally like seven lovies
his bottle with water in it a book his
favorite book
and so he's like he walked into them he
walked into the bathroom like a little
ninja i mean
just brushing her teeth and we were like
yeah
we're like oh
so i take him back to his room we say
okay sweetheart
i'm gonna sit with you and he says daddy
chair
just tired
so tired oh that's i know what that is
that's the bash traverse when he was
like losing it
tired can we get that sound bite i know
it's not polite but it's pretty good
we'll put in the request with zach
i'm looking through his database here i
don't think we ever pulled that one yeah
yeah we still have dan's story and love
yeah and love dan go ahead what do you
got for me oh boy so
it's gonna be hard to surpass a donkey
kong story but
keep looking at her yeah it's so funny
because i've been that high and i just
know how fast how horrible
i wish i enjoyed it i have so many
friends that i wish really wish i did
same same seas i hate being high
there's nothing good about being high
literally me being high i just think
about that
it's donkey kong
it's just this what's the worst i'm
sorry i mean
but i remember you were on a podcast
once and you were talking about
i forget what game you were playing and
you were high and you just kept riding
on a horse for like hours oh no
i wasn't tripping balls when that
happened oh okay i was playing yeah i
was playing skyrim
yeah oh yeah right just on a horrible
trip where we took too much we someone
told us it was a
small amount but it was like a big
amount and we were just and the whole
week everyone was like the other people
that took it they were like oh it's so
mellow and so it's such a melody
you could never totally fine me and ela
were never able to communicate
we were not able to talk we were in the
same apartment but like
totally not even universes yeah i was
literally just
i was like okay how can i ground myself
right now i love skyrim i've been
playing skyrim a lot
and so i was like i'm just gonna go play
skyrim that will help
and i think i must have for five hours
straight just
running on a horse in a straight line
and we would try to like
put music on and we couldn't listen to
music we couldn't do anything
oh man just running oh god on a horse
you know what's crazy i think i went to
school the next day oh yeah i went to
work the next day yeah
that's the craziest part is we woke up i
remember like eating lunch with everyone
at school like totally like
it doesn't really have a very bad yeah
it doesn't have like a just
not really that was one of the most
surprising things is that like by 12
o'clock the next day
i was like thank god yeah yeah i feel
like
fine but it was thank god it lasted like
15 hours it was crazy
jesus you guys said something like you
felt like
you were going to be stuck that way
forever oh yeah yeah
15 hours a long time to be like that bro
i just i was
running and it was snowy and i was on
the horse
and i was just running and running i
wasn't doing
anything just running and i tried to put
on music and it was just the worst
yeah of course where it swears first
do that in grand theft auto i used to
try to climb to the highest building
then just walk off
or walk to the highest mountain just
walk up it and then just jump off
somebody might read into that yeah is
that a cry for help maybe
doesn't everyone do that grand theft
auto i mean i wasn't even doing anything
i was just
running and running and running
there was no objective sam and i have
have got high together
one time and it was so traumatizing
really
again we went and saw the sonic movie
you thought
yeah it was inedible yeah it's different
we haven't tried this specific one
before and
uh yeah it came out on valentine's day
so we were like oh this will be kind of
a funny thing
and like 90 seconds in i just look over
and sam's gone
and i go out and yeah i go out into like
the lobby
and she's just wandering around looking
like super
terrified and i
i go up i'm like are you okay what's
going on and she's like
he's he's so fast
fast yeah and i was like it's okay
it's all right we'll be fine and sam you
want to come comment on this
i'm sure she doesn't want to get into it
but that's okay
um yeah and i tried to calm her down but
then as she was telling me how fast
sonic was
i started freaking out and he is fat
he's as fast as [ __ ] boy yeah and we we
sat at one of those benches like when
you head to the auditorium
just like grabbing each other seriously
we are like it's fine it's okay oh my
god
some gummies or something really yeah
i'm not sure what it is you guys
not just fail are you just thinking
about how fast sonic was for a minute we
were we sat there a little too long
i think and then we just went and sat in
the car for like hours
just trying to like wait it out you know
what it'll probably help that high if
you guys watch the jstation sonic exe
video a good point
it kind of purged so what was it about
sonic speed that got to put you in that
phone
i don't know he's just blurry he's so
cool and the theater was like pretty
much sold out so we were like
in the in the front right where the
screen's like right above you
you know yeah he's so fast dude
holy [ __ ] bro there are horror videos on
like tik tok about sonic killing you
i've seen those in the and he always is
too slow when he kills you
what yeah everything about sonic so yeah
come on
why is everything coming down to sonic
like nobody even cares what the frick
what the freak love you have one you
wanted to show up
no i didn't what happened why are we
talking about sonic yeah
go ahead dan stand up dan
stand up shredder's looking do i need to
get up
nice go ahead appreciate that love that
for you
[Laughter]
you love that phrase now yeah i know i
love that for you
um all right so my story uh
was also is also school related it was
uh in college
and um it was when i went to film school
and
in one of the uh courses that i had the
way it kind of worked was like this uh
we basically shot an episode of a tv
show and it was like
you worked on the crew and it was kind
of like the simulated experience where
all of the department heads
were like actual professionals that work
in the industry so like the director
the assistant director the
cinematographer all you know all those
people were like the teachers
the teachers and then you you work for
them like you would on a
crew and so i was in the production
department
um and helping the assistant director
and i had kind of gotten into it with
this guy because
the that um you know the time that i was
in the class the guy that normally
was the director was on vacation or
something or sick leave or something
so the assistant director was filling in
he was directing
um which meant that he wasn't really
paying as much attention to
instructing me on what i was supposed to
do and one of my responsibilities was to
make the call sheet
um and so the call sheet for anybody
that's not familiar is basically
just a spreadsheet that has all the
information where to show up
what you know what time to show up you
know when lunch is going to be all that
kind of stuff
and i didn't do it quite right and he
called me in the evening to like chew me
out and he was kind of a dick about it
um and i kind of like stood up for
myself i was like hey man like you
didn't you didn't really even
explain how to do this so i'm not sure
why you're like calling me and yelling
at me because
you know you were too busy directing the
show to
tell me how you wanted it done and he
kind of calmed down he's like okay fair
enough so
i had already had sort of had it out
with this guy right
so i believe it was the next day
um they were shooting and he was in the
uh
video village and he was kind of like
directing the episode or whatever
and while we were actually shooting i
didn't really have that many
responsibilities so i was just like
standing around
now this was in 2010 which was in the
early era
of smartphones right and i believe is
the first smartphone i ever had it was
like an
a droid uh something or other
right and in those early anybody that
uh had a smartphone in those early days
probably remembers that they were
by today's comparison kind of shitty
they they were kind of buggy they [ __ ]
up sometime
and the guy who was uh directing the
episode
uh that i had had it out with he was uh
he was taking it really [ __ ]
seriously um and he you know he was like
hunched over
you know staring at the monitor the
thing is this is all just a simulation
it's never nobody's ever gonna watch
this so i just like found it kind of
goofy that he was
taking it so seriously and so
my girlfriend at the time she had been
there for that whole
conversation when i had it out with him
and i wanted to
shoot a picture of him now obviously
while you're recording
you shouldn't really be taking pictures
and especially you shouldn't have the
flash on that would be a really bad idea
right
so i of course turned off the flash
before i snapped this little secret
picture of him
well my phone to this day
i don't know did it didn't register
and that flash went off
and his head snapped over and looked at
me
and if you look in the discord ethan i
just um
shared are you picture with me i love
the photos i still have the photo to
this day
oh my god so if you want to put that on
the screen real quick
this is the three heads of people
snapping over and staring at me
right before he stood up and started
screaming his [ __ ] head off and what
a [ __ ]
the guy closest yeah you can tell he's
ready to like
punch you oh my god
you did not just yeah yeah and so
he basically just stopped everything and
uh
it just chewed me out in front of
the entire class just everybody that was
there oh my god
yeah that's pretty did you have to
explain why you were taking a photo
i just i was just profusely apologetic
and it's just like obviously
because i had just the night before like
had it out with this guy
and i like had kind of successfully
defended myself from him
like he kind of like was like okay
you're right or whatever but obviously
he already kind of like had me on the
[ __ ] list
and then here i you know my goofy ass is
standing there just like snapping a
picture of him
in secret while they're filming the
flash goes off which like is visible on
camera too
by the way like so it kind of [ __ ] up
the shot it's just
shiny his shoe
i thought that was greg paul when i
first saw this photo
that's so funny that you have the photo
yeah right because
yeah so i've held on to that and i uh i
don't take pictures on set
anymore that like traumatize me forever
i don't i don't
i just don't take pictures this was when
was this in your life
it was in like 2009 2010 and what were
you doing at the time
i was in school this was in college this
was college yeah right
yeah yeah that's very awesome oh my god
yeah so i that's that's stuck with me
for years anytime i think they're all
looking at you yeah
yeah did it like it flashes before it
takes a photo
that's epic
[ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it's awesome love that so
yeah i had i thought of a few others but
then that just like hit me and i dug
through my old photos until i found that
i was like i
to show the photo so like uh he's all
serious
got his he's all like got his thinking
hand up that's what i'm saying is like
i've
i've i at the moment was finding him
cringe because i'm like
like dude like because again this guy
wasn't the normal director so it was
kind of like i had this
idea that it's like oh this guy thinks
like this is his big chance he gets to
pretend he's a director
you know what i mean and so i was trying
to like goof on him and take the picture
to
that [ __ ] own yeah i got [ __ ] hunt
[ __ ] own big
man that's great
love you got one you want to share i
have another one
yeah i do have i'm kind of
arguing with myself if i should tell it
it's not
it's like just pure cringe and there's
no fun love that passion
all right and so it wasn't that long ago
it was two summers ago
me and some friends went traveling in
europe
[Music]
by train and we had everything booked
out every hotel booked everything paid
for
and like halfway in we had like this big
fight the group like kind of split and
when you
we all booked uh hotel rooms that were
like houses
so we could live in a house what did you
guys fight about
just how what we did like some people
wanted to do that
and some people would want to like go
around and check on
like just i don't know just basically
how the trip was laid out and what we
did in the cities
and yeah so uh halfway in we did
like can i just have this big argument
and it i was with
three people who kind of didn't like how
we had planned
and then there was like five people who
thought the other thing
and it ended up the two people who were
on my side
ended up going home they left
they didn't and i stayed because i had
already paid for it
and i didn't want to like waste it so
i stayed with all these people who
basically at this point hates me
oh my god we traveled through europe
together
i didn't want to like give up with the
money i spent so
i just went along with it and it was
terrible oh no
well hold on how did you guys i thought
so
you guys parted you wanted to part ways
but then you ended up going with them
because you were by yourself or what
happened no we couldn't part way because
we had booked airbnbs
that's so we had to live together that
that's what was booked and every the
whole trip was booked
that we were going to and we stopped in
multiple cities
you guys know
i mean it was just well we kind of did
but it was just awkward and we still
yeah it was just everyone everything was
super awkward
there's no fun in it just awkwardness
you guys got in a really vicious fight i
guess and you were the boss
you were the the leader of the of the
mutinous group
no i mean i don't know but yeah
those two who were on my side left and
it was just awkwardness the rest of the
you trip your allies that is yeah that
would be pretty cringe
that's why love doesn't leave the house
now uses a robot exactly
and how long was the trip um
about one and a half weeks so we were at
that half point
so one and a half weeks after we
traveled
yeah group group
trips are difficult right group trips
are the worst brawl i'm not going on
another group
for sure like the the the um besides
meeting you
on the earth the israel trip i did it
was like birthright oh
[ __ ] it was like so not fun i'm so glad
obviously it's so funny because
obviously it changed the course of my
whole life and meeting you yeah but the
trip itself as a group trip was just so
brutally horrible horrible i just it was
so bad
it was so horrible i mean everyone there
seemed to love it but i think it's not
it's really not for someone like you but
what does that mean
it's like i don't know okay here's what
it is it's a lot of like
we're gonna we're gonna do group
activities and you're gonna break out of
your shell
yeah i don't like breaking out of my
shell i like my show
you know let's uh we're gonna today
we're gonna do arts and crafts together
so you all get to know each other
hate that [ __ ] you know what love story
reminded me
that one time we went to greece with
your friends
yeah and we rented the car oh [ __ ] that
was awesome
we went to greece which was really fun
but my friend was like we have to get
cars
because how we're going to get around
athens would you actually find without
by the way
you totally don't need a car athens is
like famous in europe for having like
the greatest brand new subway system
that is like incredible and to even
think about driving around would be so
idiotic
but so the thing is we got
my fr i think i want to blame this all
on my friend yeah
he got stick shifts but here's the funny
part
none of us know how to well we all drove
stick shifts at one point
but but we hadn't drove in a stick shift
in a long time
and so we all arrived in greece
and get this stick shift car we're like
oh yeah yeah we could do this
and so first he goes he's like he's like
i can drive a stick shift
this friend of mine is a really goofy
guy and so
even in the lot when we go to pick up
the car it's like
he's driving he's like
it's like these dumb ass americans in
greece
trying to like you can't even try like
it's
we look so stupid so right out of the
lot
you know what i'm saying and so we look
duke it out you can't do this [ __ ]
it's so embarrassing get out
and then so then shawn was with us right
right and shawn
we all had known how to drive stick
shifts at one point in our lives
and then so sean gets in and we're like
taking off we're driving a little bit
and then it's like the car
breaks and then we're like okay i think
ela
or me i think all of us try to go okay
okay i'm gonna try
i was like i mean i got my license on on
a stick
i drove for a year on stick shift i
don't know what happened
no i definitely do you remember what
kind of car it was
bro it was some like it was regular or
whatever
yeah just some four-door
generic [ __ ] you know honda or something
do you guys keep stalling out so
eventually i try ila tries everyone
tries we can't we're like okay there's
got to be something wrong with the car
there has to be something wrong with
this car
i think our friend gets back in he's
like i'm just going to do this because
we got out of the lot and we're just
stuck in the middle of track things
we don't know where we are where we're
doing four moronic tourists
who rented this car and literally it
just stuck
because none of us idiots can drive it
so our friend gets back and he's okay
i'm gonna make this happen
it's like crazy you know it's like yeah
and then the car stops and starts
smoking
we destroyed the
absolutely destroying we [ __ ]
destroyed this car
it's smoking oh no
it is the worst way to start a trip like
can you imagine
this was for our honeymooner thing
we're like we're gonna show up and this
is this is the beginning we're like dude
so get this we called the back the
rental company
and we're like dude there's something
wrong with your car
it's not i think you gave us a defective
car
it's smoking and [ __ ]
so some dude cruises out on a motorcycle
two of them and he's like what the [ __ ]
is this he's like all right my homie's
gonna take the motorcycle back and i'm
gonna take the car
so we all got out
and guess what this [ __ ] gets in
the car
and he takes off no problem
he literally drives off smooth as a
daisy
no problems and we call it taxi
go to our hotel and we're like wow we
really
are so bad but we were just like dude i
think we [ __ ] destroyed that car and
we never heard from them
wow and but like we don't even need a
car
yeah we're like we're kind of glad that
happened
there's no parking in athens there's no
oh [ __ ] that's funny bro the fact
we all looked at each other like when he
drove off like nothing
like no problem no problem
we all were like wow
wow oh [ __ ] with five of us taking turns
destroying that thing till it was
smoking
it's crazy i don't know how i forgot
about that
yeah that was a great one
as an i have a bunch man
the scare pewdiepie one and i did scare
pewdiepie and i got stuck on the roof
yeah that was a good one you've told
that story in the podcast before it was
a long time ago
if you want to tell it again but that
was horrible that was a good one
i was doing scare pewdiepie
i don't know what's wrong with me they
gave me an ear
they call it an ear bug so the producer
can talk to you
somehow i get this [ __ ] thing stuck
in my ear they put me on a roof
okay they put me on a roof by myself
there's like this big set
and they're getting ready like pewdiepie
is supposed to be running out
and zombies are chasing after him and
i'm supposed to be like yo you got to
save me off this roof
so put me on the roof i got the earpiece
in my ear and i'm literally stuck up
there
for [ __ ] hours they're not shooting
and this earpiece gets stuck in my ear
and so i start
trying to get it out because it's
getting it's irritating me a little bit
i'm trying to get it out
and every time i try to get out it goes
in more and more and i start like doing
like this
trying to get it out it starts to hurt
i'm up there panicking nobody there's
nobody around me there's nobody talk to
me
i'm up on this roof panicking with this
ear
wig earbud or whatever you call it
earwig right dan
yeah here we and i'm just picking it and
picking it and picking and picking and
it's getting worse worse and we're
closer dude
it's getting so painful and then i
actually what happened was i was trying
to tear it out i broke it in half
and i was just trying to get it out
there
by myself tearing at my ear i've broken
the piece now
there's no sound coming out of it and
i'm trying to tear it out so now i've
got a laugh
and i'm like oh the sound guy can hear
me the sound guy's listening to me the
whole time going [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i start going
sound guy if you can hear me i need help
i was like i have an emergency sound guy
i need help
this earwick stuck and it hurts a lot
and i just i really need help
no help comes i was like okay this guy
this guy can't hear me
so they're getting ready to shoot
and um i'm like yo guys listen
i need help so they bring me down from
the roof
after being up for two years two hours
freaking out they bring in the paramedic
with pliers that supply it out of my ear
and i see the sound guy
and i'm like bro what's going on didn't
you hear me crying for help
he's like yeah i heard you he's like
that's not my job
he's like i was like you [ __ ]
that's
that sounds like a lot of sound guys
there was a pyrotechnic guy
he was setting a pyrotechnics in front
of me like down right below me i was
like yo can you call for help i need
help and he's like
that's not my job nobody will help me
yeah what's happening
hey
well we messaged him and because i saw
that he's watching
and i said you got a story why don't you
just zoom in and tell us your story
uh yeah i'd love to tell my story i'm
also uh sitting here and
judging dan's uh sound by word yeah
i know well listen i i you have years of
experience at this point
compared to me um my story
um those these stories were great they
were cracking
um my story is very awkward and cringe
and it involves
a teacher you didn't it's not [ __ ]
on the lawn
no i'm proud of that one right
now i'm very proud um
involves uh my senior year of high
school
on graduation day a teacher of mine who
was like a mentor to me
and it was right in front of my family
and a bunch of other teachers and he was
giving me a hug and it was one of those
weird
awkward side hugs where my arm
accidentally grazed his dick
and it was in front of a whole bunch of
people and it was just such a cringey
[ __ ] moment well how did people know
you grazed the dick that usually just
happened
it was just so obvious it was just this
weird like
my hand touched like everybody was like
zach touched his dick i mean how would
they even think about it
well no i in my mind i felt it i mean
everybody was looking at the teacher
what did the teachers
respond it was an unsaid just like get
the [ __ ] out of your moment like
did he know you know what said what's up
do you think he thinks you grabbed him
it could be
did you grab him
the dude was my mentor like i'm like
it was the most awkward [ __ ] cringe
thing of my life
oh my god you got a good feel for his
junk though like it sounds like you took
a good scoop at it
it was it was a great it wasn't as it
was a craze
because i've grave i've grazed men's
junk really doesn't sound like that yeah
it wasn't that humiliating i mean
accidents happen in my mind it was
cringe
and like i still cringe thinking about
that and every time or anytime i hear
the dude's name i'm like
there's i think it says something
interesting about you that you're
grazing a man's junk because like
a well i think it was just the scenario
that was in front of like
everybody and like it was the last day
of high school on graduation
let me just get a let me just understand
here i mean everything at high school is
like extra time
embarrassing you know i'm just trying to
understand the situation
so he's face so here's the audience in
front of me and he's standing like this
yeah and then if eli comes and hugs me
from the side
so you hug me from the side and then how
did your hand grip
yeah it was right like that it
accidentally like just grazed
caught was she a tall guy uh he was
shorter than me
so you come in for the hug and then her
she comes in for the hook from the side
and her hand grazes right over yeah
it doesn't seem that bad to me zach it's
cringe in my mind dude i
i still cringe in it was he still your
mentor after
i think he was a little more than my
mentor after that
giving you a tour of his manhood it was
very uncomfortable did anyone in the
audience comment like yo you grazed his
[ __ ]
uh no no nobody even knew this happened
no but i knew it happened
oh i feel like i'm having a heart attack
right now
what i swear to god i feel like my left
side of my chest just
seized with pain are you clenching
i've passed what does clenching mean
like what you said that you were doing
no my [ __ ] was not clenching at that
moment thanks for asking i want to say i
do that too i do quench my [ __ ] you
do
yeah why do you do that yeah why do you
do that
i mean maybe it's like a tick or i don't
know it's like a like
erase your blood pressure um not
necessarily
it's just kind of a it's like a uh it's
a kegel like you said
well ethan has an excuse zach i'm not
sure i'm understanding why you clinch
your [ __ ]
sometimes you know you you go up and
down dude i don't know
i don't know i don't i'm weird dude i
don't know
joker brain thank you zach feel better
okay buddy
guys dan i'm watching you thanks for
checking it out feel better better
thank you just doesn't seem that bad
i do think it's interesting of to
analyze zach's psych i mean i've grazed
[ __ ]
you didn't move on you just like you're
like okay that happened let's just
move on you don't hold on i mean to me
the pooping on the lawn is way worse
that's way worse
that told a story when you had to make a
diarrhea and you just pulled onto some
anonymous person's
house and [ __ ] that's way worse than
grazing a dick
way worse
oh so i have this story it's probably
the most embarrassed i've ever been in
my whole life
really and i don't i don't know if it
will hit for you guys as hard as it hit
for me
but i'll tell the story regardless sean
sean good friend you got a long long
time viewers will know sean
uh we grew up we were like best buds
growing up we lived close to each other
i
we were all close with our families i
knew his family his mom and dad and his
sister were all really close
and one day i would cruise up to his
house like every day during summer
walk in through a side gate and in his
backyard and then go up to his room and
hang out
so one day i cruise up i go in the
backyard and his dad is in the backyard
sunbathing he's like in just swim trunks
he's just chilling he doesn't have a
shirt on
but what shocked me about it is just
that his dad had this
it's ironic for me to say this now but
he had like
a huge belly okay and it just surprised
me because
he doesn't he's like really fit he's
like a contractor he does physical work
so like he looks like strong and normal
but like when i saw him i never seen him
with this shirt off and he was like
he's he just had this i've never seen a
body like that a huge belly
and so i go up the stairs i'm like hey
brian whatever that's his name i go
upstairs to my
deshawn's room and i just go up there
and i was like i was trying to be funny
i guess
i was just a douchey little piece of
[ __ ] you know back in the day just
trying to be funny
and i'm like sean your dad is so
[ __ ] fat like so mean like so mean
you know
so mean over the top just unnecessary i
was just trying to be funny i was like
i can't believe what i just saw he's so
[ __ ]
cat and then my and then my buddy's
looking at me
and he's looking at me like making a
face
that i didn't understand like
and i was like i look behind me [ __ ]
dad
came up right behind me and was
listening to me the whole time
and i was wanting i wanted to die
and the thing is that i actually liked
his dad a lot
and i was just like ugh
so much pain oh man i was like oh brian
i was just i don't know i was like you
apologize like i just said
i was like i'm sorry i think i was just
the pain of impact it was like shot by a
bullet of
emotional pain yeah i was just
speechless
[Music]
that was the most embarrassing
embarrassed i've ever been in my life
i feel like every time one of us tells a
story like brings back some repressed
memories
yeah it's funny because this is
reminding me of a story now
tell me but maybe we should just move on
now
hold on hold on you're just going to
tease us like that
well it reminds me of the time when uh
we were in israel and my sister was like
planning i think we were playing like
where to go for a restaurant for some
birthday
and um my sister was
planning to go to a restaurant that i
didn't want to and then
i don't know why i was upset and i was
gonna text ethan
like my sisters
talking kind of [ __ ] about her and i
sent it to her
and i was like like you said it feels
like
you shot yourself so
well also there's so much pain because
it's like it's like why did i
say that it's like you would never say
to their face
you would never say something like that
to their face what did she say
your sister must have not taken that
nicely no
but i was like listen i'm sorry i didn't
really mean that like that it sounds
worse than it is
so you probably still remember those
texts to this day probably i remember
that moment still
it was awful what kind of stuff you said
like really mean [ __ ]
um no but it was like it was just mean
i know like when you talk yeah yeah
that's bad yeah that hurts
that hurts yeah i heard about people
who like send like a picture of their
dick to like
the wrong person that's wild
that's there's too much risk in sending
taking dick pics bro there's just too
much inherent risk
yeah you know what i mean there's too
much
not even once yeah i've never taken a
picture of my dick i mean not friend not
to send anyone
just for your own i mean you know when
you're young you're
why not i deleted immediately afterwards
though
immediate deletion
all right we got a bunch of good stuff
here we have so many funny videos to
watch
yeah we've already been going for
uh 100 minutes
oh wow hour four well let's see we've
got jail talk i mean leo let's get into
these are good stuff
by the way do we have the food yeah the
food yeah let's bring it here
no what about who's gonna be there for
another hour and a half
you're pregnant you gotta eat we're just
gonna munch on burgers while we're doing
the show oh my god
yes well just be quiet i'm not gonna
munch into the mic don't worry
you say that yeah every time listen i
promise
so this i don't know if you guys have
been following this okay
there's this whole just so i don't know
how people are so dumb and operate in
this world
so there's this conspiracy theory that
by getting a covet vaccine
yeah you become magnet your and your
injection point becomes
magnetized well i think it's i i think
it's related to
the conspiracy theory that there's um a
microchip
yeah you're getting chipped when you get
uh which for some reason
why would that make metals i mean
there's a magnet in your tracking device
like
well in some of the video it as we'll
see like in some of the videos
it's that people take a magnet and stick
it to their arm
and they're saying you know people go
there's a metal under there and
therefore
but then there's people that are even
dumber than that okay that just sticks
something that's not magnetic like
metal i guess thinking that the chip
itself is the thing that's magnetic
i mean none of it makes any sense so
so anyway this this whole thing is just
so dumb because
clearly when your arm is sweaty
there's going to be a lot of tension
surface tension
i mean you can pretty much stick
anything to your sweaty
part really yes there's a lot of surface
tension i mean
you never tolerate that
if you get like a slick like
stick to your arms slick little i guess
yeah yeah from the grease and stuff
right and so anyway here here's this guy
who went viral on tick-tock
thank you
he goes look it sticks to my arm
proof that there's a tracking device
right and this and this guy's putting a
magnet
that is like a little magnet by the way
it's just
it's like use your head what do you want
to people
you see the injection it's clear liquid
you're telling me there's a tracking
device in the clear liquid
that is enough metal to attract the
magnet
yeah and meanwhile they're
recording the proof of this on their
smartphone and uploading it to tiktok
like every every step of that is you
know a thousand times more
invasive to your privacy there's just no
need to put a chip in you like we all
carry around
a tracking device that all hours of the
day anyways it's just it's so much
so many great videos but none better
than this one
the guy disproves his own theory on tick
tock watch this this is part one i think
he goes explain this right you can see
that
i don't know if you can see the comments
maybe not if you're not logged in but
the top comment
is somebody suggesting the idea for the
second video
so here's the second video someone says
yo
do this again but put baby powder that
removes the surface tension
okay so to prove that this is not my
sticky skin
i got baby powder
that we're gonna put on my arm so it's
impossible for it to be sticky now
okay and if this sticks i'm going to
freak out
well it doesn't okay so don't freak out
hang on ela that's what he said hang on
hang on look at this i would like to
issue a public apology
you gotta be an idiot oh my god okay i
gotta respect the guy who's immediately
immediately willing to reassess his dad
i agree
unlike some of these other people i have
a lot of great videos of
her here's a woman at city council
who's like this is she's like look at
the proof
of this conspiracy she goes to her city
council meeting
and she's like what is going on here and
what's especially even funny about this
presentation
is that she's using a key which is made
of brass
that isn't magnetic at all
and using it as proof that that there's
some
magnetism yes vaccines do you harm
people by the way so i just
found out something when i was on lunch
and i wanted to show it to you we were
talking about
dr 10 pennies testimony about magnetic
vaccine crystals
so this is what i found out so i have a
key and a bobby pin here
explain to me why the key sticks to me
it sticks to my neck too that's it
it doesn't yeah so if somebody can
explain this oh that would be great
look at that stick for like once
any questions checkmate atheists um when
did you like take a shot
right you know it's like lady have you
tried google i mean
what the [ __ ] this is all facebook's
problem this is all facebook's fault
i guarantee you these people this is all
fictional
but watch the faces of the people for
this is her homie i think
explain to me why the key sticks to me
she's like oh my god bro
but then watch homie in the back here
too when the experiment failed she's
like this
lady is looney tunes yeah so if somebody
can explain this
that would be great it's not sticking
watch him any questions yes
can someone explain this i mean
literally
plenty of people are trying to explain
it to you lady
there's another woman claiming her arm
is magnetized but i like how she goes it
sticks to my shoulder
and my neck as if her whole body's been
magnetized
yeah this this covalent vaccine turned
me into a x-man
here's another magnet this is the arm
i've got the thighs are shot in
and there it is
got him that's where i got the shot guys
it's so stupid and here's the magnet
on the arm i didn't get the shot
you don't figure it out we're tricks
we're all [ __ ]
you know what at least i got the vaccine
kind of impressed by that i was
wondering about that i'm surprised
how many people unless they're just
lying about getting the vaccine oh
but then that would be next level i mean
it's possible no because these people
really believe what they're saying
but they're all i'm sorry but they're
all a bunch of freaking yeehaws
and don't play that music dan
i went down to my clinic i got that
covered shot and now i'm magneto
zach has everything memorized where this
is he's got thousands of sound bites so
it takes me a minute to figure out where
he's got this stuff stored yeah
shout out to that i agree with you at
least they got the shot
right yeah that's kind of impressive so
shout out to them
okay you tell me do you think this video
is a joke either there was some debate
but there's something before i showed
you she turned off the comments
and i examined the rest of her tick tock
account and it there's no
evidence of any of this being a parody
she's a christian wifey which also i
think is like
she's into like gender traditional
gender roles and all this stuff
trad wife is like turner do you call it
no trad
yeah but because i've seen a lot of tick
tocks like this that are jokes but maybe
this is the one that's real
i'm a non-tried wife you are definitely
not a trad wife
trad as [ __ ] as you'll see all right so
so let's watch here's how i start my
husband's husband's day off right i
start by writing down three reasons why
i love him
oh god then i fill up his water bottle
to make sure he's hydrated
next i start on his green protein
smoothie make sure he has good nutrients
for the day can't forget about the aloe
vera juice for his gut health
the most important part to have good
energy would be iced coffee with some
almond milk
once i'm finished with all of that i
start on the cleaning process because of
course who likes to wake up to a dirty
kitchen
not me before i wake him i put on some
christian music
and then i gently wake him up with a
little hand squeeze
here's how i start my husband's day off
right let's start by writing down three
reasons why i love him
i think it's serious unfortunately
long-term psychotic though
imagine okay like
something wrong is going to happen in
that house yo who wants to wake up like
let's banana analysis he's hydrated
waterfall on his green protein
make sure he has good nutrients for the
day can't breathe aloe vera juice cool
breakfast i mean breakfast the most
important part to have
energy i'm on board you know
once i'm finished with all this this is
where [ __ ] goes sideways the cleaning
process because of course who likes to
wake up to a dirty not me
get cleaning woman before i wake him i
put on some christmas i miss the best
and then i
gently wake him up this [ __ ] is
psychotic
this is so psychotic gently squeeze his
hand
notice how he squeezed mine back dude
your husband is a ch
is a literal a child
squeeze my hand gently mommy
is like a real man do you think a real
man should set his alarm clock and not
wait for his wife to gently squeeze his
hand in the morning
what is he convalescent he's in like a
convalescent home
and he needs he needs a white board of
uh
car here's how we start my husband's day
off this part is psychotic
three reasons why i love you because
here wait wait i want to read this
you show love merry and compassion
to everyone everywhere
you meet he's like yeah listen
honey i don't really give you got to
stop doing that
you put others happiness before your own
hey honey uh you squeezing my hand a
little too hard yesterday morning
um can you just a little lighter please
on the hand squeeze it was a little rude
awakening she probably googles this like
things i love about my husband
here's one you are unapologetically you
goofy as can be okay goofy i mean
not such a compliment so if they have a
day where they kind of fight or
something then the reason it's gonna
change like
you're strong he beats her up you're
strong
i don't know these people are not right
then i fill up his water bottle to make
sure he's hydrated
next i start on his green i like some of
these though ela
make it i'm just saying
if you want to make me like coffee and
smoothie and [ __ ] in the morning that'd
be dope
gently i'm going to make you up next
time i wake up before i'm going to
gently squeeze your hand
[Laughter]
seems like a creepy way to wake up
gently squeeze his neck
a little more a little more
it wasn't waking up dude there's so many
great videos this week here's another
one
it's true love when you're walking home
from you're from your one-night stand
and he gave you peppa spray to protect
yourself
teeth oh my god
oh
giving her pepper spray and wishing her
luck
that's pretty that is pretty alpha
i wonder what that christian husband
would have done
eddie bravo dude this i i don't know if
you guys are going to find it as funny
as me
but i could not stop laughing at this
this guy eddie bravo who's that what's
the story with this guy dan cause i'm
not really familiar
uh he's a frequent
uh guest on joe rogan's show he's really
into conspiracy theories and stuff i
think he was originally a ufc fighter
yeah martial arts instructor right
currently i believe he was uh
an mma or something alone and we should
just note as you can probably tell from
the
studio that they're in this is an ultra
clip but i don't know it's still funny
as [ __ ]
so watch how he just dude oh god
bro like do you know that uh eight
hundred thousand two thousand to a
million kids get kidnapped a year do you
know that
is that real i don't know look it up i
don't know why would you read that
i don't know i mean somewhere online i
don't know if it's true
i've never seen someone crumble so fast
why'd you say it then
but he says it's so confident yeah he's
like almost
he's like upset about it too and he's
like did you know that did you know
wait and he's not a comedian no no he's
a 100 serious right
eight hundred thousands
that's like a comedian moment do like
did you know that most men sleep with
like 10 000 women in their life
really i don't know look it up i don't
know it's just not as funny as him yeah
let's get kidnapped a year do you know
that is that real
i don't know look at him where'd you
read that i've never heard him
i think that's something i don't know
it's true do you know that uh
800 000 i mean joe rogan going to fight
once about his conspiracy theories it
was pretty funny is that real
i don't know look it look up up
why'd you say it then
this guy is tripping on tick tock
super deep like deep christian guy
this whole tick tock is about giving
praise to the almighty but
he takes it way too far this good watch
this if you don't tell people about
jesus either you don't believe in him or
you hate
everyone around you see to believe in
hell and not
warn somebody about it makes me question
if you know about it
if you know the person who talks about
it
how much do you have to hate the people
around you to say nothing about hell
you have the key to heaven you have the
path you have the map
and you're willing to stay quiet so
either you don't believe in jesus
or you just hate everyone else around
you bro
don't forget this whole concept doesn't
make sense
just maybe or just maybe both i would
gladly spend
eternity in hell than share the same
space as this guy
for eternity you know what you mean
every single one of his videos
he's crying like his eyes are like
bloodshot from crying
i will gladly spend my life in hell fire
than than listen to this [ __ ] guy
how does he go on with his life he's
just like terrified the whole time he's
got to tell everyone
like that's crazy this guy's ready to
start a cold
this guy's like one breakup away from
like a
starting local where he like impregnates
a bunch of underage girls and [ __ ]
can i just make a comment a quick
comment about eddie bravo he i guess he
is a comedian but he was being 100
serious in that moment
oh he's for the record he does do stand
up but he's known for
being a conspiracy theorist and a
martial artist first like
yeah i think everybody who hangs out
with joe rogan decides like
i'll go do a stand-up comedian i mean i
think
it would be funny to be a comedian well
like he was funny
like i'm a comedian i don't know
am i a comedian you're clown
you're a funny you're an israeli clown
who called you that
yeah am i comedian you guys yes
oh you think so of course it's hard to
tell because you don't do like
stand up for example well dan's a
professional hater i don't know if he
has disqualified
nice plane well what is dante no yeah
you're a comedian
oh my god you don't have to do stan
you're not a stand-up comedian oh my god
you guys think about that
you're a sit-down community yeah sit
down down there oh my goodness
you know you sit down working when you
do comedy for a living i would say that
qualifies you thank you so much
that's so meaningful to me
because i don't want to be like eddie
bravo and be like i'm a comedian yeah
yeah yeah weird when you're like on
youtube you feel like you can't
claim any title you're a sigma comedian
you make your own lane here's another
one from this guy
which god are you serving you though get
this gods on golden statues
sometimes gods could be uh
[Music]
i just pierced through this phone this
god
of yours but get this
you you pierce through my god too my my
god
you pierce through him and he he still
loves you
the only god that can ever give you
satisfaction
you pierced him maybe
it's time you toss away things that
aren't giving you satisfaction
like fake phony rich from a guy who's
got like 100 bracelets on
dude obviously cares about material
possessions with so many bracelets
what is it about wearing lots of
bracelets it's just it's it's the
telltale it's a universal signifier
that has bracelets like that a bunch of
them on their wrist there ain't
something there's a screw loose and if i
smash my phone how do i watch his
tick tock right yeah right good point
why is he on tick tock
that's a mega good point
why are you on tv these gods these idols
that give you
no worth and start worshiping the one
god who does
the true god who is pierced for you
if you really unpack what he's saying
there's one god true god
everyone else is going to hell and dying
yeah
it's like okay bracelet boy why can't we
take a [ __ ] break bracelet boy go
take a walk
in all these videos it has like friday
the 13th music playing
yeah right for some reasons why all of
his videos are like it's pretty amazing
yeah you want proof of god
no okay fine look around you
look at the ocean look at the fish in
the ocean look at the trees look at the
birds
in the trees look at the stars look at a
baby being
born look at the sunset
look in the mirror we can't put god in a
test tube
but we can look around us you know deep
down inside this is not an accident
there's no way the proof of god is all
around you
you just don't really want to believe
that he's real
because if he is oh
if god's real that means it's
not looking too good for you okay but
god loves you so much
he gave you a way out a way out from his
wrath
so he sent his only son jesus
to die this is like the wally tic hog
it's way too long
[Laughter]
jesus replaced you with god
you want proof of god okay
look around you look at the ocean look
around
look around proof look up do you want
your phone
look around look around you
look at this burger i'm eating
meat tomato lettuce
how could this have happened
at pugs freakish animals made by humans
by the way
look at the fish in the ocean
you want to watch more of his i have a
phone here that's been pierced
straight straight through check out my
last video
but but get this there's another man who
was pierced for you
a man named jesus christ oh wow see you
have sinned you have fallen short from
the glory of god
get it this way imagine if i key my
neighbor's car right
i run his track right right through the
paint it's not that big of a deal yeah
same thing maybe someone will catch me
what if i go to a chevy dealership now
i'm in federal trouble
now if i go to a ferrari dealership
what is he where i'm going you have
scratched the car of a holy god you have
fallen
short of jesus you're not a good person
but god was pierced for you so you
wouldn't be
and now you're gonna spend eternity with
him in heaven
crazy
the christians to go like jesus died for
your sins they're basically
it's like i can do anything i can do
any heinous crime imaginable as long as
i accept jesus
we got to put up we we need some kind of
barrier to be like
not you you know what i mean like jesus
got to lower his standards i don't buy
this [ __ ]
look at what goes on in the church the
worst of the worst that goes on the
church at any say you know what goes on
there
we need a barrier where jesus is like
not you you
you not you i don't like this
you can do anything you want because
jesus died for you not you
because jesus died for you
i know what you did not you
he's dude and he's not trolling guy
right oh no no people are
no this guy's the real deal yeah
um
but there are some christians in the
chat saying it's hard to watch as a
christian
yeah i know of course i mean this guy's
just on the loony
yeah yeah
um watch this one bro again
elected official
i'll let it speak for itself
first service and maybe give me a little
more volume damn
oh wait it's not turned up
no it's going to be through i understand
so this is um
congressman louie
gohmert
listen to his solution to global warming
from what's been testified to the forest
service and the
blm you want very much to
work on the issue of climate change i
was
informed by the immediate past director
of nasa that they have found that
the moon's orbit is changing slightly
and so is the earth's orbit around the
sun
we know there's been uh significant
solar flare
activity um and so
is there anything that the national
forest service
or blm can do to
change the course of the moon's orbit
or the earth's orbit around the sun
obviously that would have profound
effects
on our climate um what
i would have to follow up with you on
that one mr gohmert
yeah well if you figure out a way that
you
in the uh forest service can make that
change
i'd like to know uh also just to
uh can we this guy should not be this is
not
okay that someone this dumb is holding
office
the dude asked someone from the forest
management service
not even like nasa she literally is in
forest management
if we could just change the orbit of the
earth around the sun
this guy is a congressman
also let me guess republican right yes
oh you guys see what's going on
i'm not crazy the dumbest people are
republicans every time
that's like a that's like a a that is a
empirical fact
i don't mean to be partisan here but i'm
just saying i'm just calling it like i
see it
this is an empirical fact i feel like
only a republic
republican congress person could ask a
force official we could just
change the orbit of the earth can you
guess which state
oh let me let me guess three florida
texas yes yeah my other next one was
gonna be arizona
i would have done like alabama before
arizona to be fair
no air zone is the looniest one there's
you guys have been recounting for like
10 years already
well that's fine yeah
come on now me down here texas have
benefited greatly from the public
education system
boy i'm a good old texas boy i don't get
no vaccines yeehaw
and no state taxes come on down now to
texas no liberals though now you're here
not that come on down to texas we got no
taxes and no queers we kicked them all
out of the state
no good it's different i can't find the
i can't find the uh music so i'm just
playing whatever
now what i learned in school was that
you could change the orbit of the earth
to fix
climate change come on now
this he felt like he was really doing
something too
reminds me of when trump was like has
anyone thought about injecting bleach
this is a good idea that nobody's
thought about yet
now the scientists take this and do
something with it
this guy's like has anybody thought
about changing the orbit of earth
now take that scientist and make it
happen
yeehaw down here in texas we learned
science and math
did you know that the earth is only 6
000 years old that's what it says in the
bible
six thousand years did you know that
bill gates hides dinosaur bones in the
earth to try to trick us to think the
earth is older than it is
we found it what
found it you found what the music oh
thank you
oh did you know that dinosaur mates were
made in a factory by bill gates to
convince us that the earth is older than
six thousand years old
what's wrong with global warming just
move the earth a little further from the
sun
[Music]
come on now i put one back seat in my
arm and now i am magneto
not so bad damn we got people i can't do
what you're trying to do but people just
go hey come on you guys
people are trying to listen
[Music]
i took one shot of that fighter and now
i can control metal with my mind
someone explained this
i just won the biggest suey competition
with my mind
i picked up a pig with the iron in its
blood and i moved it in the air
after i got the pfizer explain that
[Music]
as a texan why do you hurt me ethan oh
stop
you know your state is [ __ ] up might
love you
we love texans you know what i'm saying
there's just a little extra yeehaw in
texas you know what i'm talking about
austin texas is cool right that's what i
hear
i just got the fizer so i'm going to
move the iron at the center of the earth
to move it away further from the sun
whoa the year is 2021.
everybody has now magnetic superpowers
after getting the visor vaccine
they can move metal with their mind and
world is that chaos
there are battling factions now moving
giant pieces of metal
weapons skyscrapers here's the brew
oh the covet vaccine has changed the
world as we know it
he's playing like this
wars are shooting armies are shooting
bullets at each other with their minds
the world is no longer the same as it
was no no no
the years 2024 everybody has
supercharged magnetic energies
men
texas says texas has seceded from the
nation using
super magnetic power they float in the
center of the
gulf of mexico covered by a giant
metal barrier cubanon was real the whole
time
a group of hugh sheamus hold up a metal
barrier around the state
of texas to shield it from the outside
world which has crumbled into chaos
splash cut to inside texas the president
of texas speaks
we didn't get them damn covenant shots
now boy
oh my god the world has totally changed
people now want as much coving shots as
possible because it increases their
magnetic superpowers
the president of texas has gotten 10 000
shots of pfizer and he can control all
metal in the world with his mind only
the president of texas launches
spaceships into space
using only his mind
all right you can cut it
all right got it please save me from
this hell
[Laughter]
oh you know what it is wait hold on give
me the sci-fi music again
uh this the president of texas
and all the followers who got pfizer now
have magnetic powers
those who got moderna have broken away
in the state of florida
and they could control lightning with
their eyes it has mutated their dna and
they've become
super humid everybody's hoarding backs
covered vaccines
in new york it's the jonathan johnson it
gives them
the power to manipulate air itself the
warring factions is called
the war of the covet shots cubanon was
right
trump has reassumed his position as
president
the election was totally fraud and trump
was right the whole time
there are those superhumans that have
got jj moderna
and pfizer and control all the elements
they are known
as the super squad
i am part of the super squad i control
all the elements
i'm on a secret mission to assassinate
no let's not talk about assassination
it's true though man don't be surprised
if you start seeing magnetic superheroes
if we could just change the orbit of the
earth
we could so we could fix we could
fix global warming my name's louis gomer
and i figured out how to fix
global warming just change the orbit of
the earth
i'm running for congressman for the
great state of texas
i could change the orbit of the earth
i you just tell the scientists and we
move the earth further from the sun
i have solved global warming
i have figured out how to stop the polar
ice from melting
i am bringing out a bunch of
refrigerators and going to open them
into the earth
and cool the south pole
my name is louis gomer
and i'm fixing the soap the polar caps
effects on our climate
i would have to follow up with you on
that one mr gomer
the moon's orbit or the earth's orbit
around the sun
obviously that would have profound
effects that would have profound effects
if we could move the earth clip further
from the sun
my name is louis gomer and i am an
elected
congressman from the great state of
texas
if we could just scoop out iron from the
center of the earth
someone says can what accent is this now
if we could just scoop out iron from the
center of the earth
we could build the biggest we could
build we could have
all the iron we want
i am
this guy's such a [ __ ] idiot how do
we tolerate this
more only idiots could elect such an
idiot you know what i mean
anyone with a [ __ ] working brain
would be like this guy is so
dumb you could understand how [ __ ] we
are
moving on
global warming is not an issue
so when the chat said is straight up
patrick telling everyone to move bikini
bottom
it's so stupid right
yeah this shit's pretty funny shout out
to her family
more tick tocks off the rails
i don't know what she's trying to do but
she gets stuck oh really and i feel so
anxious watching her like oh just
circulation to my feet
i feel so anxious just move your leg out
please
she's got a solution though she's gonna
slowly low i don't think she's stuck
no she is she said it's a circulation of
my feet
oh well now she is stuck look at her
legs
love her though great attitude
[Music]
if we could just
i have a solution if we could just
travel back in time
and bring technology back with us we
could just
invent solar energy before we farmed the
gasoline
yo this meme is so prolific on tick tock
lately
have you guys seen that you're not that
guy pal
no i don't think so
so it's like well here i'll play for you
you're not that guy pal trust me
you're not that guy
absolutely if you're not wait can we
find the original
uh this isn't this guy was trying to um
i guess they're having a confrontation
at the self checkout at ralph's where it
all goes down
and he's like are you going to try
something you're not that guy pal trust
me and he says are you he says
absolutely
so now all the time it's just become a
really great meme where it's like
any time someone tries to bounce and
pierpong yeah
pal trust me you're not that guy okay or
the one i saw recently like when you try
to pick my main and smash against me
absolutely you're not that guy pal trust
me you're not that guy
okay okay he reminds me of brian regan
you know that stand-up comedian
yeah so brian regan the uh the originals
and the discord here here it is i love
this
love it oh how's that
how's that how's that [ __ ] such a
great voice don't tell me what the [ __ ]
to do how's that pal
i didn't tell you you did you said don't
talk to people who you don't know i'll
talk to whoever the [ __ ] i want to know
never mind
how's that bill never mind i did tell
him not to talk to you that's right so
use your [ __ ] head if you know how
understood okay you little pimply little
[ __ ]
you guys got such a great voice that
sounds good to me there's something to
leave
i'm checking out sir this guy's an
anti-vaxxer for sure by the way i just
put that out there ring out if you guys
if you could take you're not that guy
pal trust me you're not that guy
absolutely you're going to get arrested
for this wrestling for doing what
just like a pimple on the left somebody
says something and you don't like it
and you don't like it right is that what
it is you little pimp
can you hold the camera while i check
i'll leave the store [ __ ] you where you
blew your plow
right where you breathed for [ __ ]
biden and suck right here
oh yeah i made a bite i knew it
you're not that guy it's just turned
into such a great meme
here here's another one when dan tries
to do the sound bites
and zach this is zach's take on dan
trying to do the soundbite
pal trust
[Laughter]
i don't believe that
you guys have any other captions for
this you want to throw out there
guy pal trust me you're not that guy
okay
yeah you absolutely i love that
yeah no i guess we could have grabbed
some more oh let's do jail talk let's
move it along jail talk is really
important
to me okay so this was the one i saw
this on my
feed and it just was so endlessly
fascinating to me and by the way
it has 3 million likes so
the views must be insane on it i mean
here let me see 10 million views
how this is a okay so watch this
when you ain't supposed to have your
phone but you're not known for following
the law
this is kind of like i have to say it's
kind of heartwarming
because this guy kind of like gives me
like white supremacy about i don't know
but he's just like a gnarly but
this is like beautiful race uh
relationship right here in jail
because like usually they say you're
separated by gangs and stuff and i just
find this really touching that they're
having this beautiful moment here like
this through the glass
look how happy they are
we don't take top we don't take time
i love these two guys this is like such
a special moment they're sharing
is anyone else feeling good
come on back me up guys this
[Music]
this is what martin luther king was
talking about
i'm not sure maybe not the best
everyone loves tick-tock
come on nobody's backing me up here this
is beautiful i'm not sure i
feel what you're feeling yeah i don't
it doesn't really seem that beautiful to
me now look how happy he is
they're both so happy we don't take time
10 million views dude i love tick tock
simply for this video alone like
where in the world could that video get
10 million views nowhere
no nowhere else and it deserves it don't
get me wrong
a message from my boyfriend
from jail yo this [ __ ] is fire a message
from my boyfriend in jail about me
dressing up
[ __ ] i don't wanna leave you baby but i
gotta go right now
he does his own backup where goes right
now right
boyfriend in jail about me dressing up
[ __ ] i don't wanna leave you baby but i
gotta go right now
right now right now right now
are you sure it's not someone else
saying they're right now right now who
he's on a phone call in jail about me
dressing up who else would be saying it
[ __ ] it's definitely gonna leave you
baby but i gotta go right now
right now right now nobody else is there
right
it has to be him right now right now
when he says go right now he turns too
perfectly
yeah that guy's a superstar man it's a
shame to have that kind of talent locked
up
you coming to a prison dressed like a
hoe right now
i love that dude it's so romantic man
heartwarming president tries to escape
through the toilet
um prison talk we out here
this is for everyone who keeps telling
me to escape through my toilet let's try
this
instructions unclear please do what this
and explain further
dude i love these guys i mean dude if
i'm in prison i need tick tock nothing
getting me through that day man
these guys can make a little revenue in
there you know get a little that creator
fund going
oh people are saying it's not him
singing
what what was that something else
somebody
dubbed over yeah i'm looking into it
right now i'm checking out my phone
it's like an audio from something else
it feels like when i thought that fart
was real but the guy was doing the best
this is from the same guy by the way
this is pretty funny
huge watch this [ __ ] all right this for
everybody that keeps asking me how do i
charge my phone
you take two double a batteries you take
a rubber band
you take two twisty ties you take a pair
of nail clippers
you take a piece of a nail clipper you
strip the end of the twisty tie
and then what you do is you push all
that to the side a little bit
you take your cord you walk over to the
wall and you [ __ ] plug it in
just
this guy's awesome right prison tick
tock
rules man that one was that one was
really solid
okay you want to see what the what kind
of food they're making in prison yeah
so there's this thing called prison wine
which is just
bruh i can i can't dude i don't i
i'm assuming they don't have alcohol in
prison which makes sense i mean
right obviously so these guys have
figured out ways to make their own
foreign
[Music]
bro look at that bro look at that
prison wine look at it oh my god
what is that that's the worst thing i've
ever seen and it's like
chunky does that really get them drunk
like these guys know how to ferment like
about why
the chunks like kombucha because you
don't have the right tools to do the
filtering and everything
they can sneak a phone and they can
sneak their filtering tools in damn it
i kind of i don't know why prisons are
run like pow cams i find that i just i
find it disgusting how we treat
prisoners like what
they run like prisoner of war camps like
what the hell it's like come on these
are citizens bro
let's give them a little humanity how
are they going to come out of prison
like
a well adjusted when they've lived like
animals
in prison like just the conditions
couldn't be worse it's just
crazy can't even put a toilet seat on
their
toilet like come on now
there's another prism wine one
what'd you say what'd you find it be
on the app it is her original sound but
it could still be stolen
some of the comments do say it is stolen
but i can't tell for sure she has a lot
of jail tick tocks and some of them are
voiced over by like songs right now
right
now i choose to believe it's real we'll
have to do a deep dive another time
i gotta go right now right now
okay look at this prison wine dude tell
me batters up
yo just get these guys some beer man
this is not a this is just
look at this oh
it looks like sewage
you know what i mean creative now let's
get him some beers
i'm fine with that here they're cooking
french fries
we can't get these guys real french
fries like i mean come on don't we spend
like a shitload of money on prisons
can't get them some french fries instant
mashed potatoes eggs flour cooking oil
doesn't sound that bad actually
um someone is saying that
it's uh true that you can see from other
countries that it works giving
giving prisoners more humane yeah
obviously
if you put them in prison then and then
just treat them like [ __ ]
total animals without any rights and
they're gonna come out
not any better than they went in that's
for sure some people come out worse you
know
there's that famous line in shawshank
redemption she says i went into prison
innocent and i had to go to prison to
become a criminal
fish patties you all ready for this i'm
fascinated by their cooking
maybe hit me with the volume dan
well like grandma old sam and pat used
to make back in the day yeah i chop up
onion and green pepper and throw that
thing off in there
put a little cheese on that bread you
know what i'm saying dress it up
and oh you see the can i got the grease
i got that
i got that patty cooking you know like
grandma old salmon pack used to make
back in the day
yeah i chopped up onion and green pepper
put a little cheese on that bread you
know what i'm saying dress it up
dude the american prison system sucks
anyway that's about it eh
um what is this from kim jail it
he sent us some more oh yeah he uh when
you mentioned jail talk at the beginning
he's like i love jail talking
oh he's got some good ones yeah nice
turn that up
into this just like this i can't hear
anything
it has this little android and then
straight to the a lot of people been
asking how we charge our phones lately
that's wrong so i'm going to show you
got this little tablet charger be on
plug that
into this just like this
has this little end right here and then
being
straight to them a lot of people have
been asking how we talk about phones
look at their conditions it's it's it's
just it's not it's just [ __ ] up bro
these people are not
animals they're not freaking
i don't know bro i don't know it's just
not cool i i really
not yeah this this is what a swedish
cell looks like from love
and i've seen a bunch of documentaries
i've seen how people are treated in
prison like
this is what it should look like this is
not luxurious
it's humane yeah like you shouldn't have
to [ __ ] in like a weird ass [ __ ]
this is not luxurious living by any
means
that's what a prison should look like a
display room in ikea
which i guess makes sense in swedish
yeah this doesn't look nice i don't want
to be there
it's just a humane
[Music]
here we have more jail tick tocks from
cam now i'm curious i think we actually
got to
wrap it up oh we do well you guys have
to we have to get home for our nanny
yeah
oh they're making like tick tock
sketches this rules
when you catch someone stealing from you
in prison and he's snatching
uh oh somebody caught him yo what's up
boom
[Laughter]
they're having fun why shouldn't they be
able to have fun in there you know what
i mean like
it's just come on somebody in the chat
james charles is watching this taking
notes
i don't get it because he's going to
jail and he's on tick tock all the time
oh
sister shanked yeah james charles should
be over there
there's no reason james charles
shouldn't be able to make tick tocks
from jail
i'd love to see that jumpsuit and
everything
see what kind of homemade pallets he can
make so how to charge your phone is
apparently like a prison meme i don't
know
oh [ __ ]
that's amazing that the guards are like
this guy's pulling more more electricity
than i do at my house
you know but what about wi-fi does just
wi-fi well you got 4g
if there's like a card in it um
a lot of these guys bribe the guards too
so yeah that's not helping him out with
that
oh they're making tick-tock memes
bruh this guy's like king of the
prison probably he's out there in the
yard and everything
sister snatched the [ __ ]
oh this one has quite a bit of views
four hundred thousand
love that for him last one
just for me
this is what james charles this is kind
of how i imagine james charles jail tick
tock with like the yellow jumpsuit
it's orange orange sorry i know it's
orange i just
oh wow this is like a whole thing
man
don't ever send me to jail please
i didn't do it whatever it was i didn't
do it
anyway that's about it we're actually
out of time even though i have other
[ __ ] to talk about
was this a fun episode yeah it was
oh that's good have fun a lot of people
have been saying
they loved this episode oh really thank
you guys
that's great i think the whole crew
dynamic the stories were fun
um i hope you guys enjoyed our video
today we dropped
i have another video coming out next
week that we already shot that i'm
filming
about the dream how like you know this
this minecrafter dream
people allegedly found his identity we
don't really know if it's him or not
whatever that's not the point
the point is about how crazy all these
minecraft kids are
and i think we made a pretty funny video
about it so this is like a video do you
see what i'm saying
we're expanding the h3 universe podcasts
plus content
isn't that exciting so like you guys are
going to get
a more traditional h3 productions video
next week on the podcast channel
interesting that's kind of my goal
moving forward is like
now the frenemies is gone is that
you know i'm just trying to think like
okay we need more like
i want to spice it up i want more kind
of content so podcasts
and content let's go
come on it's sucks
[Music]
it feels so quiet this time i think it
must be because zack's gone yeah and
dan's not dan's usually yeah
yeah dude i'm so tired i'm kind of i'm
kind of fading fast here
i'm gonna be honest because it's been a
long week let's be real
and we started really early today
because we shot another video which you
haven't been hinted at
this morning before we started so we've
been working all day today yeah
for you guys we shot an amazing sketch
today that's gonna we're gonna use next
week
i'm just saying we are working so hard
for you guys
yeah you guys did great work love you
guys you guys did really good work this
week
you as well okay thank you sir thank you
thank you thank you thank you
shiva right you're so
anyway guys thank you so much for
watching thanks for you know
it's been a wild week right thanks for
tuning in
i'm feeling optim i really am feeling
optimistic though about the
future of the channel i'm feeling
motivated i've got like a good vision
i got a great team the team makes all
the difference i couldn't do it without
you guys honestly
make it all possible thank you so
i'm now i'm feeling optimistic anyway
have a great weekend
i don't know because we usually we do
friend me's on monday
slash tuesday so i don't know if we're
gonna have anything on monday or tuesday
but
we're gonna try i think we will oh
really maybe the dream video yeah
that would be awesome so we might have
to actually have this dream video
for members on monday and then for
public on tuesday
yeah i'm really curious how you guys
like it
really interesting thank you guys thank
you thank you thank you for all the
support
and the love and for being here and
supporting us i'm just i'm excited
thank you thank you let's go with peace
and love peace and love peace and
love is a serious message from ethan on
friday afternoon peace and love peace
and love
can i eat your leftovers
we'll give it here then you're gonna
keep eating
yeah okay well what are you waiting for
to finish the show
we're done go ahead and eat all right
take us out thanks everybody
you